We, we are ready to start the meeting.
We, we are ready. We'll give a couple minutes to quiet down.
Can you hear me okay, Lacey? Uh, yes, I can hear you.
Okay, perfect. We'll go ahead and get started. Uh, before we
call the meeting to order, I've asked Brett Wright, Council Member Wright, if he'd offer
a prayer. So, uh, when it's quiet there, Brett, if you'd, uh, lead us out.
Our Heavenly Father, we're grateful this evening to be able to bow our heads in
prayer and express gratitude for the opportunity to gather as fellow,
fellow citizens. We're grateful to live in this
great city, in this great state and in the United
States of America and to be able to enjoy the freedoms and opportunity
to pursue life in the way that we choose.
We express gratitude for the many blessings that we have, for the safety that
we enjoy, for one another's camaraderie and companionship.
We pray, Father, as we're about to embark in several
hours of discussion and opportunity to listen, we pray that thou bless us with listening
ears and listening hearts. Bless us with those of
us who will speak, those of us who have come with an opportunity to express
comment and thoughts and, and with
a desire to help the city council hear the concerns that
they may want to raise. Bless those that will speak with the ability to articulate
their words, to be able to do so in the allotted time.
Bless us with civility one to another. Bless us to be
appropriate in our actions, to maintain at all times the
decorum that is expected in this public setting.
We express gratitude for our employees, for our first responders,
for those who are serving in the military. We pray that we'll be mindful
of them and their families. Bless us to be aware
of those who are less fortunate than us, those who are in need.
Help us to continue to be the great neighbors that Eagle Mountain is known for.
And these things we humbly pray in the name of Jesus Christ, amen. Amen.
Amen. Okay,
thank you, Brett. I appreciate it. Um, it is 6:02,
and we'll officially call this meeting to order and, uh,
ask that everybody stand and join Craig, who's going to lead us in the— Councilor
Whiting will lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance. Yeah, if you could join me
in the Pledge of Allegiance.
Okay, thanks, Councilmember Whiting. Uh, just to start off,
a couple of housekeeping items. First of all, I appreciate everybody accommodating me being remote.
Uh, I can see a full house there, and I appreciate everybody showing
up. We love it when people participate and, uh,
come to the, to the meetings to help us make
these difficult decisions for our city. Uh, I love
technology and the fact that we're able to still join. I see
there's quite a few participants online as well. Mayor, we're having
a hard time hearing you. If you could speak right into the mic, it would
be greatly appreciated. Okay, is that better?
Yes, thank you. Okay. Yes, we appreciate you guys
being there, and I'm sad that I'm not there in person due to a
previous obligation, but I appreciate the fact that we can still join remote and have
these same conversations. So, with that, we'll start.
I saw— it looked like Natalie was passing out some packets.
There are packets at the back of the room with the following documents
available, just for public knowledge. It is the property tax
impact schedule form from Eagle Mountain City.
Also, a physical copy of the Utah County Notice
of Proposed Tax Increase is available for review.
The agenda is in that packet as well, and the Truth
in Taxation overview or basics. And also, for more information,
you can visit em.gov for— or eaglemountain.gov
for additional information on our website. I know our communications
team's kept that up, and it's, uh, it's been very good.
So any other information that you're looking for,
hopefully those are the areas you can find it. And if you need a packet,
it's at the back of the room. Um, we're going to start with the
agenda item 3A, which is the public hearing for proposed Property tax
increase. Uh, there will be some rules, just like as our, uh,
other meetings, some decorum. As was mentioned before,
we expect everybody to be respectful and to follow the rules and,
uh, make sure we handle this with respect. This public
hearing is for the proposed property tax increase. Please keep your
comments related to this topic only. The council will listen
to all comments but will not engage in a discussion until the public hearing has
been closed. Each person will have 3 minutes to
address the council.
We ask that everyone remain respectful throughout the hearing.
Disruptive behavior, personal attacks,
cheering, booing, clapping are not permitted.
If this occurs, we'll— you'll be asked to leave the room.
If you've submitted a public comment form online, Lacey will read your name.
To see if you're in attendance to give your comments. After all
comments are submitted, the meeting— in
the meeting have been addressed, we will invite those attending in person to speak first,
followed by those participating online. So Lacey will help us
manage that. Everyone will have a chance to speak if you so desire.
And we'll go in the order that she sets forth with people in
person, the ones submitted online, and then those online.
For those attending virtually, including email,
by the way, for those attending virtually, when the time comes, uh, Lacey will
call your name and will electronically ask you to unmute your microphone.
Your 3-minute speaking time will begin once you start speaking.
You're welcome to remain in the meeting to observe, but you will not be able
to provide additional comment. Everybody gets one chance.
If you prefer, you may continue watching the meeting through the city's
online streaming portal. Please make sure to speak clearly
into the microphone. After all speakers have had the opportunity to comment,
the recorder's office will conduct one final check. We'll check to
make sure everybody's had a chance. If you still feel like you haven't had a
chance to speak, we'll allow one last chance and then we'll close the public hearing.
So, I've read those things again. Order of events, we're going
to start with public comment prior to the meeting, then the participants in attendance,
then the virtual ones. Then email. Lacey, have you,
uh, heard those instructions and do you feel like there's any clarification
needed? I think you hit everything perfectly. We will go
with it as we go, so we're good. Okay,
perfectly. It is 5:07 on the 6th
of August. Correct. Hang on, Mayor.
Hang on, Mayor. Uh, you're in a different time zone.
It's— I'm— yeah, 6:07. 6:07,
sorry. At, uh, I look at my clock and that's what told me.
So 6:07 on August 6th, um, and we will
now open this public hearing. So Lacey,
I'll turn it to you to call up in order. Sounds great.
We will go ahead and start with John Breeding.
So I went online earlier today and I looked up that since
2020 we've had about a 78% increase in revenues.
We've had a population growth of about 60%.
Inflation's run about 29% since then.
And an 11% increase in taxes would
give an inflation-adjusted equivalent of what we
had for revenue in 2020. I'm kind of cynical.
I believe that a 220% increase
is kind of a head fake that I don't think anybody here actually
believes that that's what is going to happen.
But when you eventually come up with
about a 40% increase in taxes, which is also outrageous,
people will be less up in arms about it.
And I don't understand why, as government, as our population
grows and as the government grows, that you don't become more efficient
with artificial intelligence and computers and
things like that. It seems like government is the only thing that
doesn't become more efficient with scale. Anyway, that's my
Chaz Roberts.
I do not see Chaz Roberts in attendance. We will include it into the record.
Melissa Bradley.
I'm disappointed. I'm frustrated. It's not the resident's job
to prevent a tax increase. Mayor, council,
you're supposed to be able to prioritize needs over wants.
I'm against the 220% property tax increase because it's
not for public safety. It's for nonessential projects
that the city can't afford. Let me be clear. I support funding our sheriff's
office. I support paying employees competitive wages. I support
needing roads, water, and sewer improvements, and you already have the money in place
do all of that. This increase is a burden on the average taxpayer.
25.2 million Americans under 35 lived
with their parents last year. That's not normal. And raising our property
taxes is not the solution. You're adding to this crisis.
Craig, Rich, Brett, you all are real estate agents.
You should understand this. Jared, you were the real estate agent. You should
know the consequences. Zach, as an investor, you should get this. Melissa, as a mom
with adults living in your home, I assume you understand. Thank you. Property tax increases
don't stop with homeowners. Landlords will pass those costs
to their renters, and our children and your residents will pay
higher rent. Families will have less money to help their kids with
rent, gasoline, or groceries. As housing costs
rise, which they are unaffordable right now, young adults will stay
home longer, and that delays their independence. Families already
caring for adults, children, grandchildren, or aging parents
have even less room in their budgets when you increase fixed
housing costs. By increasing our property taxes, each one
of you is choosing to negatively impact 26 families
in my neighborhood. In one week, that will be 27 because my
kids are moving in— my adult kids, 2 of them. When you're
proposing what you're proposing is wrong, it's dishonest. When you claim it's for public
safety, it isn't. It's for completely optional structures like a
new city hall and rec center. And the fact that you had the city manager
admit that on Tuesday instead of standing up and saying
it for yourselves is crap. I hope you choose to lead with honesty
moving forward. When you took your oath of office, you all promised to be faithful
stewards of the taxpayer dollar. The people of Eagle Mountain work
hard for each dollar they earn, and they're making difficult financial decisions
every day. We want you to do the same.
We have contracts in place. And they will benefit our community
soon. Be patient. Focus on public safety,
sewer, water, and roads. 30 seconds remaining. Stop looking
to the taxpayers to solve your pretend budget crisis.
We don't believe you. Go attract businesses to expand the tax
business, and you— and then you better leave residents' sales
tax alone. I caught that in Tuesday's meeting.
It is our right to decide When and how we want to spend our money.
Stay out of our pockets. Our community wants freedom from taxes, not slavery
to it. Do not raise property taxes and no new taxes.
I'm just going to remind you that the mayor gave us clear instructions that we're
not going to entertain that. Clapping was not part of those
instructions. Yes, it was. So we're going to ask you to
refrain from that type of outburst because it's going to delay the opportunity
for those who want to come and speak to us. So please
refrain from that, or according to his instructions, we're going
to ask you to leave.
I do have Adam Brady for the next one. It does say
my wife Melissa will read the statement. I am unsure if he's here. Adam Bradley.
Sorry, you have to hear from me again. Good evening, Mayor and Council. My name
is Adam Bradley, and I'm here to strongly oppose this proposed 220% property
tax increase. In fact, I believe you should be lowering taxes and not raising them.
A 220% increase is an enormous ask.
Saying it's justified simply because property taxes haven't been raised
in 15 years is an insult to basic math. This represents
real money for families already struggling with inflation,
rising home values, and higher taxes across the board.
Eagle Mountain's explosive growth has already expanded the city's
revenue through impact fees, building permits, and commercial development.
So why isn't that growing paying for these needs?
I've seen no convincing evidence that existing revenue can't fund
competitive wages for our employees, and I've seen no categorical
proof that we need more sheriff deputies.
Comparing Eagle Mountain to other cities doesn't work. There's no
other city like Eagle Mountain. Show me the 911
calls that aren't being answered. Show me domestic violence calls
going unanswered. Show me crimes not being solved. I haven't seen
that evidence. Until a few days ago, residents were told every
dollar of this tax increase would go to public safety. Then people started
doing the math. The sheriff's contract increases by roughly $1.5
million while this tax hike brings in about $6.7 million. Order.
Only after residents started asking questions did you admit the
rest is for other projects, including a new city hall.
This was never just about public safety. I've also
heard almost no discussion of alternatives. Where's the debate?
Where are the compromises? One council member even told my wife to
do the research and come back with ideas. With respect,
that's the job that you were elected to do. When I
served on this council, I said no all the time because protecting taxpayers
came first. Growth should be allowing us to reduce the
tax burden, not asking families to pay more.
I'll leave you with this: Have you forgotten the proper role of city government?
This council and the last have continued to grow government
and spending. What happened to Eagle Mountain being a place that
that valued limited government and respected taxpayers. Please, no more.
Please vote no on this increase and start looking for ways
to lower our property tax instead. And on a personal note,
I would like to add, I love
Adam. 30 seconds remaining. He was a great council member,
and he worked hard.
You're, you're reading his statement, not your own.
You don't get to go twice.
Ben Bracknell.
I don't see Ben Bracknell. Um, it says opposition to proposed tax increase.
Um, I do want to remind those of you online, uh, for the Zoom link,
this is for participating virtually. If you want to watch the meeting
and not participate, you can go to our portal to watch it. I do have
Alex Washburn, uh, for the public comment, but I do see you're online,
so we will call you when the virtual time comes. Um, Ashley Lauer,
or Lower,
um, it only says property tax increase. I do not see
her, but we will add it to the record. Duncan Searcy.
Sorry, I didn't hear the mayor say no clapping. He was quiet,
but I also don't think our First Amendment rights care much about his decorum.
So the title of this meeting is Truth in Taxation
Public Hearing. I want to quote the city. This is what
they said. Eagle Mountain City is proposing a property tax increase
with every dollar going straight to public safety,
period. So that's a lie, and we all know
that now. And so that's not a great way to start this meeting off.
I was a lot nicer on Tuesday when I spoke, but some
of the responses I got from you actually is what made me upset, and I'm
not gonna be quite as nice tonight. You'll see some of the pensioners I mentioned
on Tuesday are here. That's great. Every single one of you, when I brought this
up, expressed remorse, like, we don't wanna be doing this,
you know? This is so hard on our community. This is just
a necessary evil that we have to do. And Brett, you said something that struck
me. You said, we have been called upon. To make this decision.
Brett, who is calling upon you to raise the property taxes
if we elect you and you work for us? I would like to
know after all this is done if you would address that specifically.
Who's calling upon you to make any kind of decision? Okay. And then
Melissa, it bothered you so much, just the thought of raising taxes on our poor
families brought you to tears. Sweetheart, you don't need to
be upset. Just vote no. You don't have to raise the taxes. This is your
choice. you get to vote yes or no. Okay? So I
think we just need to realize everybody
is struggling in this economy, every single person.
Okay? If we as citizens are tightening our belts and
we're deciding what we have to cut out of our lives, so must
the city. Okay? There's money coming down the pipeline.
Mayor Gray preaches about it all the time. So let's— Thank you. Tighten up our
belt as a city instead of pushing those tax
burdens onto the regular person. Okay. And Melissa,
I'm sorry, I'm going to call you out a little bit. I'm tired of the
performative testimony meeting style emotion.
It's manipulative. Okay. And you have the chance tonight
to vote no and prove that I'm wrong and that you really do care about
the poor families. But when you sit up there and get emotional, it really
bothers those of us that have discernment. Okay? A big reason
why we're here tonight is because you gave Meta, a $1.5 trillion
company, a 20-year tax break. Okay?
Had you not done that— 30 seconds remaining. I don't think we'd be in this
financial situation that we're at. And you keep touting this
infrastructure that Facebook has brought to the city. I have never once
driven out to the Facebook building, probably never will. They have not improved
anything in the city that we, the citizens, use on a daily basis.
So stop trying to gaslight us into like,
oh, Facebook has been such a good deal, this is such a good deal.
We're tired of it. Start working for us, or next election
we are going to speak even louder. Your time is up.
Thank you.
Ryan Parker also
does not say— just says property tax increase. I do not see him here,
so we'll add it to the record. Charles Peterson.
Good evening. As a former federal government program
analyst, I have more questions than answers.
So in reviewing all this material,
What I'll give you is some questions.
We've moved here— well, we've been here for 10 years now and so
on. So I've got a number of questions that bother me. A couple of these
things have already been mentioned. Of the
$6.9 million,
and with $1.5 million for the
added police officers, I would be curious what
the analysis was done— sorry, as an analyst— to
say how do we need that
many more? And it's already been addressed a little bit. Is our
public safety been reduced without these?
I don't know. That's a question that I have.
Second— is
looking at the information that was available, by going and approving
this, we will become the most— I think the second most property
taxed city in Jefferson— I'm sorry,
I'm thinking of my own old county, but in Utah County,
we are now second best. And I was
reading a piece talking about being so
wonderful about how our taxes are low. Now,
if this is approved, we're going to go right up to the top. Excuse me.
The other thing that bothers me as an analyst is
the other— what is it?
About 5. Yeah, 5.4 million goes
into public safety.
Now, is there a fund called
public safety? What happens to that?
Is there an outline of all the things that you're going to do with
this $5.4 million?
I haven't seen anything.
So what we would expect as an analyst is to say,
okay, and I've had a lot of dealings with budget analysts.
What are we actually talking about? What are the line items and
what are those results going to be? 30 seconds remaining.
I think that's critical. And if you can't show that,
then we ought not to be voting for it, frankly. Thank you very much.
I do want to clarify that we We do have Ryan Parker online, so we'll
go back to his comment, but he is virtual. Dave Bresheenahan.
Thank you.
Mr. Mayor and City Council, thank you for allowing me the opportunity
to speak. I'm grateful for each one
of you, and I know how tough your job is. I really
do. I wouldn't want to be in your position.
The people that you represent, the people of Eagle Mountain,
which has a median age of 23,
and approximately 44% of our population
are under 18, which helps us to see this is
a community filled with a lot of young families.
Then there's people over 65, like me.
We only make up about 3% of Eagle Mountain. Young families
are just getting started building careers and do not
have a significant income, with the median individual income of
$48,105 per person.
The average retired couple have a combined income
of $79,315.
We are all strapped for cash.
The cost of living is making it harder and harder for the
average family to get by. The added
proposed tax adds to that burden and makes life more difficult
than it already is for the vast majority of all these
young families. I got my numbers from Google,
by the way. Eagle Mountain charges an impact fee
on new residential and commercial development.
That fee is intended to fund the expansion of
services because of the impact of that development.
A portion of that impact fee is intended for public safety.
I know about impact fees because I was a member of
the legislature when we voted that into state law.
I go back a ways.
Families, young and old, have a specific income that must be
budgeted to take care of all the expenses for their family.
As the cost of living goes up, families must find ways to cut
corners and tighten the budget, which means shopping sales,
using coupons, using Facebook Marketplace,
and they do without A lot of times in
order to make it all work. 30 seconds remaining. I would suggest
that the city has the mechanism to pay for additional services
that come with the growth of the city through impact fees. I know
developers hate those fees,
but it's a part of the cost of doing business.
And they are making millions in Eagle Mountain.
Those impact fees won't affect their millions.
Hopefully, the city can find ways to become more efficient in
the services that the city provides. I ask the city
council to— Your time is up. Thank you.
Brian Free.
Great to be here today. I want to thank you all for not kicking the
can down the road. Uh, seems like the trend since I've lived here for 20,
20 years. The can keeps getting kicked down the road so we can keep our
taxes low or whatever, and the needs of our city continue to grow. We're a
growing city. There's needs and they have to be taken care of. So thank you
for that. Um, I, I think that goes a note. I, I also want to
say that a lot of us have probably had a knee-jerk reaction to,
to a 220% increase, which is actually lower if
you add in, you know, your fire and your sheriffs
and put that all together like another city would have in their city tax.
We're probably right in the middle, and then we're probably at the top when we
add 220%. So that's, you know, so that's more of an apples-to-apples
comparison, which is good to do. I think one of the issues is there wasn't
a lot of transparency, right? So we're not seeing what you guys are seeing,
and that may not necessarily be right on you, but on those who were
tasked with putting out information for us. Um, we like to see what all those—
we like to know that it's not 100% for one thing, one portion, that it's
for a bunch of things that are all needs within our city. And, and seeing
those line items is really helpful so we can see exactly what it's paid for.
There may be a lot of us that would say I don't like it,
but those are all needs. I don't know how we don't take care of them.
And if we saw what each of those things are, right, and maybe we'd have
some different, different type of discussion because we would all come more informed without
having to dig deep to try to find those answers. On our own and do
that work that could easily be provided for us because you guys already have
it, some of that information. So that would be very helpful for us to see
what those line items are. I will say that in
addition, one of the things that we want to make sure we're doing is that
we're taking advantage of looking at the things that,
let's say my basement's flooding, I got to get that water shut off and get
that water out of there and clean everything up or I'm going to lose my
home, right? Those are the kind of things we need to take care of.
And I know we have some of those kinds of issues. In our city that
need to be addressed that maybe we don't always see day to day as residents.
And so that's important. Um, but 220% or the lower
number, if we include everything together, whatever that percent is, it's still an increase.
It's still a tax, um, with everything else like has been mentioned that, that we're
seeing increase in our lives. And we want to make sure that that's being— um,
we're looking at zero. Let's say we can't do anything, zero, without going into
major debt to do it. And then add to that, well, what can we do?
And then what can we do in 2, 3 years when some of that data
center money starts coming off? Like, when they first were talking about data centers,
we were told whatever the size is, one data center is like 4 or 5
Costcos or Walmarts worth of revenue. That's a lot of revenue.
If that starts coming on board in a couple years, we've got a lot of
revenue coming our way, right? So we'll be able to— we should be able to
then reduce taxes. 30 seconds remaining. But one thing I'll leave you
with, just because it's a buzz term,
let's not California our Utah.
A 220% increase is a California in our Utah.
And that's something I don't think any of you want to do or any of
you are in favor of. Most of you would consider yourself conservative, fiscally conservative,
and I would hope that you'll really take that into consideration. Thank you.
Matt Oakman. I don't see him
online and I don't see him in person. We'll add him to the record.
Matthew Endicott.
My name is Matt Endicott, and I've lived in Eagle Mountain for about 6 years.
I've listened to the presentation given by Chief Deputy Knutson in April, as well as
the comments I've received from the city council in response to my email this
week. Um, thank you for your responses. Um, but I seem to have missed some
important discussion in Tuesday's meeting. Um, I'll have to go back and review
that. After reviewing of the budget that was released earlier this week, this issue has
been made clear. The messaging from the mayor was confusing and
may have led to the level of negative responses being voiced, but after review,
I have a couple of questions. Based on my review, the proposed public
safety budget is about $10 million, which is, you know, based off of other things,
which is about $2 million higher than last year. This revenue from
property taxes last year covered about 50% of the previous costs,
with the other 50% coming from the general fund. So sales tax or
other things, if I understand that correctly. So I have a couple questions. Why is
it necessary for the entire amount of the sheriff's contract to be covered by revenue
from property taxes? Was revenue from the other sources projected to fall below
the needed amount to cover the contract amount, or are there
other budget areas that need a roughly $4 million increase and this tax hike
is being done under the guise of public safety because that is an easier sell
than other programs? With this switch from using the general
fund along with property taxes to only using
property taxes for the sheriff, will the general fund be reduced
a proportionate amount to reflect the change, or is the city— total city
budget raising the $6 million?
With the increase in sheriff deputies, is there any changes to the contract to
make sure we are being protected and that the increased presence won't be used for
generating revenue through tickets or over-policing as seen in neighborhood cities such
as Saratoga Springs and American Fork? I understand, but have my disagreements
with, the comments made by the Sheriff's Office and the City Council that Eagle Mountain
could use a larger police force. I also understand there has not
been a property tax hike in Eagle Mountain for a number of years. These 2
things being understood, why did the City Council feel the need to swap 100%
of the costs, including the $2 million increase, in one year? Could it not be
possible to continue using alternative revenue sources for the Sheriff's Office with a modest increase
to property taxes to cover the $2 million increase? Why was there the need
to switch the entire $10 million over to property taxes? This seems— this
just seems to me, and I imagine a number of folks here, a dramatic increase
to the size and scope of the city under the guise of public safety to
avoid having to have discussion or try and sell a less popular budget item.
Thank you. Andrew Burke.
My name's Andrew Burke. I've been here a couple times, a couple years back,
like 5 years ago, and then recently moved here after we built our home last
year. I'm gonna make this short. I do agree that the police office,
the Sheriff's Department has to be supported. I do believe that, you know, we do
need to, based off the research that I've done, we do need to increase it
0.45 over 1,000 residents versus the average of
about 0.8. I mean, some of the stuff the chief deputy said wasn't accurate,
like Saratoga's at 1.56 per thousand, but I'm not going to go into the
semantics. Um, I do agree with the previous speaker that
I don't think that the property taxes should be the thing that's covering
all the increases. And I think my biggest issue,
and I think most people would agree, is that the
transparency is just not there. Why can't you give us— if you've allotted a certain
amount for improvements under
the guise of public safety, why can't you give us
an itemized report before you say, yeah, we're voting on this? Let us know
what you're increasing.
So, I mean, it's frustrating because everybody
is struggling. It's harder. Like, I heard a comment about AI.
A lot of us don't know if we're going to have jobs in 2 years.
Because AI is taking away the workforce.
And, you know, now to sit there and say, hey, 220% right now,
we haven't done it in 15 years, right now, without gradually
rolling it out, it's almost criminal.
Like, why would you— why would you do that to us? You were— we voted
for you, and this is how you repay us?
Now, I'm not against Increasing the budget for our sheriffs.
Public— that is public safety. But $6.7,
almost $8 million increased with no itemized budget?
That's not acceptable.
So my question is, if you are going to do this, can we get an
itemized line for line on how every dollar is going to be spent?
Because if you're not going to do that, then don't pass the bill.
That's my time.
Kelly Horton?
I don't see Kelly. Can I take his time?
I'm not on the list. You can— Can I take her time?
You can fill out a paper. I'm right here. Oh, you're there. Oh, I'm sorry.
No worries. It's all right,
you can take your own time. My name is Kelly Horton.
I've been here since 2016. You know, I first want to begin by saying
that, you know, we really do support our public safety here. We love our law
enforcement out here. I don't think anybody's going to disagree with that. Our firefighters,
first responders, everything they do every day. It's not about whether they deserve
support. They absolutely do. I said this is about whether asking
residents to shoulder such a substantial tax increases
the only or the best solution. Many of us
are already struggling. The cost of groceries, utilities, insurance,
and housing has increased dramatically. Families are making difficult choices every
month just to stay afloat. For people living on fixed incomes,
seniors, and residents with disabilities, even a few hundred
dollars a year can make the difference between paying bills and falling behind. You know,
before asking taxpayers to pay more, I respectfully ask, You know,
what specific spending reductions were made before deciding to
raise taxes? You know, what programs or projects were delayed
or eliminated to demonstrate that every other option has been exhausted? You know,
why is the increase— this increase being proposed all at once
instead of being phased in over several years? You know, what guarantees
can you provide that this won't become the new normal with additional
large increases in the future? How will the city measure
whether these additional tax dollars actually improve public safety,
and will those results be reported publicly?
Transparency matters. Residents deserve to know exactly
where every additional dollar will go, how success will be
measured, and what accountability exists if the expected results are not
achieved. You know, Eagle Mountain has grown rapidly. That growth has
brought challenges, but it's also brought additional homes,
businesses, and a broader tax base. I ask that the council to,
to please explain what that growth alone— why that growth
alone is not enough to help meet these needs. And most importantly,
please remember that behind every tax bill is a family. You know,
for, for some, this may seem like a budget decision, but for residents,
it's groceries, it's medicine, it's gas, it's schools,
clothes, it's child care, or keeping a roof over
our heads. You know, I respectfully ask the council to reconsider the size and
timing of this increase. If additional funding is truly
necessary, consider a phased approach. Continue identifying spending efficiencies
and ensure residents are fully informed before placing a greater financial burden
on them. Thank you for your time.
Anthony Wood.
My name is Anthony. Um, so true,
true representation means reflecting the will of your constituents.
When you must convince us of your narrative, then that's
manipulation. The tax increase is being advertised
as a need for increase in law enforcement. The supporting stats
that are being used are how many officers there are per 1,000
citizens. I don't like that. I don't like
that number. What I do think we should be looking at is the crime rates.
So if we're using some of the comparative cities you guys were using in the—
in the how many officers per capita, Sandy is 32
in 1,000. Means you're going to be— you have a chance of being a victim
32 times out of 1,000. For Lehigh, it's 22 per 1,000.
Do you guys have any idea what Eagle Mountain is? It is 1
to 1.2 per 1,000. Our crime rate is
very low. We see our officers,
multiple vehicles per stop. That's what we get to see as citizens. 4— 3
squad cars, 4 squad cars per stop, per incident.
We see them at the gas stations. It doesn't look like they're crazy busy.
Right. They may need some support, but this is the wrong way to go
about it. You're asking the wrong people to pay for this.
What I mean is that there are a lot of corporations, like we were talking
about with the data centers, that are getting those tax breaks.
They do a lot of damage to our infrastructure, our water, our roads,
and they're not contributing to that. I was looking at the repairs to Pony Express,
and it took us the end of '24 and '25
to finish Pony Express, and I went on there the very next day and I
rode it. I ride a motorcycle and I rode it. It's garbage.
I don't know how much you guys spent on that, but it's trash. It needs
to be done again. Who signed off in saying that that was okay?
Another example about the spending, and like, I would like to
focus on budgeting what we have first before we ask for
more. And another example that I have concerns with,
with how we spend our money is that in 2022, in August, we spent— we
sent $1.13 million
to a scammer. Just money gone. Like, we need to budget
what we have before we ask for more.
I agree, we may need more, but I need to focus on
the budget before we get there. I mean, I don't lend money
to family members and friends that are irresponsible with money,
and I don't want to do the same thing here. Can you say that again?
I don't want to give you more money. I don't trust you guys with it.
I mean, sending money to a scammer, I have to teach my grandma not to
do that. I don't want to have to teach you guys not to do that.
That's all I have.
Bruno Hunsaker.
I don't know about following all these guys that's been up here.
Some great comments. I'm just
going to represent the old guys or the old women. We're the seniors.
So most people on Social Security, the average,
like Brett's mom, is probably $1,300 or $1,400 a month because
she's been on it. I'm about $1,800, so I'm a
little more fortunate. So I give you $300 extra.
And so— and we're on a fixed income. I'm lucky
I still work part-time, so it's not going to affect me as much. But these
young families that they've all been talking about.
So we get $300 there. And those of you that don't know what's going to
happen next year when this mighty new school district comes in
that you were all buffaloed into voting for,
they're going to start out $200 million in the hole. So if
you think the City Council is going to charge you $300
more on a $500,000 home, you wait
till next year's tax intrication when the district
is going to raise that up probably $300 to $400 plus
a bond the next year. They need 17 schools in the next 15
years, and they're a pretty small school district to do
that. So I'm just telling you, I hope you all show up next
year in total force when that school board meets to increase
your taxes. And also, I agree on some of those
roads because I ride a bike too, and It's
supposed to be a soft tail, but it really is a hard tail on that
road. So anyway,
I support law enforcement. I don't know what the crime rate is.
I'm thinking per capita, it might
be as bad as West Valley City because all I ever hear is domestic this
and domestic that. They're doing their job, and I know they
need an increase. Thank you. But like everybody else said, how many building
permits? We had the most building permits in the state of Utah
in Eagle Mountain last year. And then I see them
build 2 homes over by Blackridge, and they brought gravel
in, compacted a little bit, and put these 2 new homes in just
to get a building permit. I'm starting to wonder if people will sell somebody
in their family for a building permit. Just that
much— those building permits and those impact fees should be paying for what
you're asking for. I know your minds are made up. I don't think you're
going to budge. I think it's going to go through, and I know you feel
our pain. So anyway, 30 seconds remaining.
I appreciate the job you guys are doing, and I know
it's a hard job, but I'm just telling people you're going to be
paying a lot of money the next 3 years between this and the new school
district. And the mayor tells me while he was a city councilman the
water treatment plant needs to be updated next 4 years, there's another
$50 a month on top of that. Thank you.
Nathan Thornburg.
Hello, I'm Nathan Thornburg.
Um, I can understand the way the state tax regulations
and codes don't help increase
revenue as property values
increase.
However, like everybody else, I have questions.
Why wasn't— why was the campaign
initially, that was initially released,
that This is gonna 100% be
to increase our public safety.
The end. Period. And we were all,
I think the way that the messaging was presented was we were all supposed to
go, yes, yes.
And it was only after members of our
community actually pressed that there was more of an explanation
given. This is going to free up money so that we can better improve
things. I think we all would have loved to hear that initially,
if money was— if there was a plan to increase revenue
to improve the quality
of life here in Eagle Mountain, you wouldn't be getting slammed
right now. You probably still would be because 220%,
as was stated earlier is
almost criminal.
Do you see how the changing of the narrative only after being pressed
erodes trust? Now we don't know what to believe. You were
either dishonest then or you're dishonest now.
Anything you say to smooth it over can at best only be
taken with a grain of salt. But most likely is just not
going to be believed at all unless you
start putting the actual money where your mouth is. I think
it's safe to say that after tonight you have an assignment.
What's the plan? Is there a proposed budget or schedule
of these capital projects, uh, that the city intends
to complete? And the only way to regain trust in this communities to follow through
with what we need. And if there
is no publicly released budget for us— 30
seconds remaining. —to have access to so that we can, you know,
maybe see— begin to see some of
your intentions, if that isn't released to us,
what are we left to believe? Are we supposed to just
trust you? We don't trust you. If there
is no line item given to us,
what are we left with?
Your time is up. Thank you. Matt Everett.
Good evening, Council. Good evening, Mayor, wherever you are. I Um,
stand to, uh, stand firmly in the minority opinion
of the people that are in this room tonight. Um, I encourage
you to pass this tax increase.
Now, having said that, 220% is a big number.
I wish it wasn't that big. I, knowing you and
the interactions that I've had, I would assume that you probably have a
similar feeling to that. In my opinion,
220% is a direct reflection of poor management
and leadership that the city has had in the past 15-plus years.
My family and I have lived in the city for about 17, a little over
17 years. I've raised my family here. I'm continuing to raise my family here.
There are a lot of things that need to be improved in the city.
Talk about roads. We've talked about infrastructure. We've talked about a lot of different things.
All of those things cost money. And there's limited ways
that the city's able to— Your actions— To take care of those
needs and the requirements that they have. Moving the
property taxes and using this increase to fund public
safety makes it a stable fund that we're able—
the city will be able to use those known dollars every
year to fund the needs of
the public safety. So this is a difficult
night. This is gonna be a difficult thing for a lot of residents. I understand
that. But I encourage you to continue on the path
of leadership that you have and to make the hard decisions
regardless of what the outcomes of those will be. Thank you.
Mark McConkey.
Others have talked about their frustration that these funds aren't being— aren't actually being used
for public safety, and I feel that pain, especially as the funds we use
for public safety now get sent out of the— out to the county rather
than being used to establish our own public safety through a city police department accountable
to the mayor and this council. Eagle Mountain is the largest city in Utah without
its own dedicated city police department. And looking at the state's border in
Utah, we're the second largest city without a police department.
Only Centennial in Colorado is bigger. In fact, if we were
to take a deeper dive on this and take a look at the size of
the largest cities in each of the states without a police department, here's what we'd
see. Eagle Mountain is twice the size of Kuna, Idaho, their largest city.
We're 3 times larger than Fernley, Nevada, their largest city without a police department.
We're 4.6 times larger than Castle Pines, Colorado, which is their
second after Centennial. We're 3.1 times larger than Fountain Hills,
Arizona, and we're a whopping 37.8 times larger than
Pinedale, Wyoming, which is their largest city without a city police department. We've outgrown
the point where we should rely on, on county support rather than owning that ourselves.
Every dollar that we send to the county for policing is a dollar that we
give to be controlled by the county, and every decision about how our streets are
patrolled is made by people who don't answer to this council or to the residents
of Eagle Mountain. Right now, as we contract with the county sheriff,
that means we have no direct say over hiring standards, use of force policy,
response priorities, or community policing style. Those decisions
are made for the whole county and are not tailored to us. If we ever
disagree with those decisions, we don't have the ability to push for those
changes outside of election season. Even during election season,
Eagle Mountain only accounts for 10% of the voter population in Utah County, and there
may well be some elections where where the sheriff runs unopposed, as he is this
year, which limits our options even more. A city police chief
would answer to the mayor and to this council and its residents, getting a clear
line of accountability. I know the first objection is going to be cost, especially startup
costs, but the city already owns the building the sheriff's department operates out of right
here in Eagle Mountain. If we convert that city to a police department, there's no
new facility building or lease. That overhead already exists.
Because our contract with the county sheriff's department accounts for about 1/3 of their budget,
likely be able to transition many of their officers to city officer positions as well,
reducing costs of hiring and training. We're not building departments
from scratch, we're being able to convert what's already here. Beyond that, the startup
and transition costs will only be higher in the future as our population
grows. When it comes to our policing options, I see
3 options: start a police department now, start a police department sometime
in the future— 30 seconds remaining. —as our population grows, or never start a police
department and be okay with not having control over our police force.
So my ask tonight is to conduct a study of the cost for standing up
a municipal police department. As we earmark these funds
for public safety, let's use these funds in a way that we can control.
Thank you. Betty Peralta.
Good evening. My name is Betty Peralta,
and I'm here to oppose the increase, and these
are comments I have. The proposed
increase, I feel, is outrageous. The justification is not
clear enough. The homeowner property rates increase,
and as our income remains the same. The property
values, especially in my community, which is Sweetwater,
continue to fall. Eagle Mountain city center and
communities look more run-down every day.
My property value alone has decreased $7,000 in
2 months. So yes, I agree with the previous speakers
that this is criminal to impose a tax
rate increase of this kind. The traffic has increased
here significantly. The roads are horrible.
And the majority
of homeowners, I'm asking to oppose this increase.
And my other question is, because it has not been
outright and truthful what these funds are being used for,
are we using any of these funds for city council staff pay increases?
I'm all in for safety and first responders. I'm a retired
38-year first responder, so I know that those are essential
and necessary needs for Eagle Mountain, but I cannot
justify the increase. Thank you.
Joseph Pill— I don't know how to say it. Not even close.
Thank you. It's French. Not even close.
First of all, I just wanna say— I'm sorry, hold on, Joseph, will you say
it for the record? Oh, Joseph Pedlow.
All right, so first I wanna say I don't wanna be being in your seats
tonight. It's probably not a fun meeting. But I
do wanna thank you for your service and the commitments, 'cause you wouldn't have run
for this position if you didn't want it. The big thing I wanna say is
just urging caution. So I work in higher education
in the state, and I've worked there for about 10 years. And over those times,
we've seen again and again when the state legislature has proposed big budget increases and
big budget pushes, and there'll be community blowup and hard feelings, and often
it gets redacted. And I think we can learn a lesson from that. I don't
think anyone here doesn't want to help our officers. We do. We want
them to be the best officers in the county. We want them to have the
resources they need. But I think we also can all agree that 220%
is a lot at once, especially since a lot of us are nervous about the
new school district. about water facilities, road infrastructure, more infrastructure as
the city grows. We're one of the fastest growing cities in Utah. So my hope
would be just to urge caution because we don't know what it's going to be
like in 3 years. We don't know if the new school district is going to
ask for a 300% increase because they don't have administrative buildings, they don't have a
bus depot, they don't have the mechanics. We don't know that. We don't know what
the water will be. We don't know what the infrastructure will be. And we do
know we are getting more stores. We're getting Lowe's. We're getting Smith's, and we
will see that income increase as the hospital comes out here and as other plans
happen. But we just don't know what that is right now.
But we do know 220% is a lot to ask, especially since
transparency has been an issue for a lot of residents. So my only advice
is just caution, because maybe this is where we do need to be, and maybe
you have very important reasons. I believe you're all amazing people who aren't increasing
this for no reason. Thank you. But we can all
agree that this is a bit of a shock in the community, and you probably
don't have this typical turnout at events like this because we're shocked
at the number, and we're shocked at the fact that we don't know exactly what
the general fund that's gonna be increasing by about $5 million, what's that
meant for? So my only advice is just to urge caution, maybe do
a smaller increase. Let us see what the new revenues will be when we get
more infrastructure. Let's see what the new property value revenues will be. Let us see
what the store of news will be, and then let us know what we need
to do. Because I think no one here is opposed to bettering our city and
bettering our police force. I think what we are opposed to is making a jump
in the dark. So thank you.
Josh Shadd.
My name is Josh Shadd. I've been a resident here for about 12 years.
Really came to me as a shock that you guys are going to increase the
taxes by 220%. So I just have some comments I wrote down.
With the increased tax revenue that will be added to the general fund and used
for capital projects, it's a little deceitful to present,
present this as 100% funding towards public safety,
as the previously allocated funds are now set into the general fund
and used for capital projects. As we build out housing in Eagle Mountain,
property taxes should increase, and Why haven't those funds been properly allocated
in the budget? And just to clarify, I don't have any issue with
increasing policing, police presence within the city limits of Eagle
Mountain. The issue I have is the communication of this city council to
its members, to the residents of Eagle Mountain, and being clear with
your guys' intention of what you intend to do with our tax dollars.
This is something that I have brought up before, is communication
from this city hall. The city hall is terrible at messaging.
You guys are terrible at communicating meetings. You guys
are terrible at reaching out to the citizens.
The only reason I saw this is because I happen to go on Facebook.
I've signed up for all your newsletters, all your text messages. I go on the
website every once in a while, but I have a life outside of this city,
so you guys need to be better at messaging.
Previous city councils have also failed to to take— to be good
stewards of our taxpayer dollars. Convince us that this tax
increase for the taxpayers is going to not
be wasted and misallocated and spent
on things that are not in the budget or are hidden or moved
to the side. On another note, I do believe we have had
a utility rate increase that's supposed to happen over the next couple
years, and that is in addition to this. So you
guys are going to be putting undue stress on the normal families of Eagle Mountain.
And I think that's pretty much it I got. Thank you guys for your
time. Mark Espinoza.
Council,
Thank you for having this meeting. Sure, big turnout here. I hear a
lot of people concerned. My big concern is,
guys, I, I had a business,
made a payroll and stuff. All the things that
you need to do to run a business, you got to make.
But guys, 220% increase?
If I did that to my customers, I'd be out of business.
So we got to do something. Everybody's so fed up that
220%— if it's 3%,
you would have had half a crowd in here. But you go to— you hit
it big, 220%. Maybe go back. I don't
know if we have time or if you're going to vote on this. If you're
going to vote on this tonight, we're pretty much, pretty much done.
You got to go back and look. How can we bring up revenue? I hope
the mayor is doing something. I wish he was here instead of
thinking that he's looking at a video on Zoom. I wish he was in front
of us looking at all these people here. But if he's making a great
deal for Eagle Mountain, fantastic. He's got
my approval. But I don't think so. It's important.
You got a lot of people here, a lot of things, especially out here
on the communication with you guys. Thank you. Go on
your website, put a link on there, and then it— line
item be— line item. It'll show everybody what's going on.
But again, bringing out the 220— come on,
guys. You know better. I heard some people
here in businesses. Shoot, you do that to your customers and
see how long you're in business. Again,
I heard fixed incomes and stuff. I came from California,
a lot worse. They don't even listen. It got so
bad, I had to move. I'm glad I
moved to Eagle Mountain. I love the place. Family-oriented, love it.
But do not, do not go down that road. There's a reason why
people move out of California. It's not the poor people. It's the rich
people. People with money, and they come in to
spend the money. Keep them in Eagle Mountain. That's one way to get the revenue.
Other ways, get some bigger people in businesses.
That's how you generate money into the coffers.
Again, I thank you guys. 30 seconds remaining.
I thank you guys for listening to us, but I hope, I really hope
you hear everybody, what they had to say. I'm retired.
I can come up here. I was ticked off working
30 years, buying a business, ticked off. I couldn't go to these
meetings. Shoot, 13, 14 hours a day.
Well, now I'm retired. I could do some more.
Thank you again, and thanks for everybody coming
out. Be sure to vote. Be sure to vote.
Thank you. Your time is up. Thank you. Jeff Ruth.
Hey, counsel. Jared. I'm going to
be the ad bono, aside from Matt, I think. But I'm
a little frustrated because this is going to impact me.
But I can't tell you how many times I've called for an officer
and they don't show up. Yeah, it was kind of minor on the list of
things that were probably going on, but they didn't show
up. Once in a while I get a call and say, hey, we're sorry,
you know, we didn't make it. But We
had this going on. Okay, that's fine. I've called for other things.
Hey, we only got 2 officers on duty this morning. We can't
come out right now. All right, fine. I've asked,
why don't the officers out here do preventative?
We can only do reactive. We don't have enough officers to
do Preventative calls.
I can't tell you all the vandalism I've seen over at Corey Ride.
I mean, it's ridiculous. Every once in a while, an officer should be sitting
out there and catch some of these teens out there busting things up,
busting up the bathrooms and everything else.
And I understand you're going to shift the money for
the officers into their kind of their own separate account.
And that's going to free up other money. How many times have I been up
here and asked you guys to mow along the roads, to fix this,
to fix that? Well, it's my understanding that if you move the
money, then you'll have the money to do this other
stuff. I mean, it's like with the voles at the
park. Max, I think, got hurt because he— his
leg went into one of those holes. I've asked it to be addressed.
Never, never done. Um,
so I mean, I love our officers. I met many of them. I've dealt with
them, and they're good. I think we need this.
Like I said, it's going to impact me a lot. I'm on Social Security.
It's going to be tough. Me and Melissa talked, I think it was at the
convention, about this, and I understand. Thank you.
It's just— but it gets me. People say, well,
bring in more businesses. Every time a big business
wants to come in here, what do you get? You can't bring that in
here. Oh, it's going to use too much water, too much electricity, this and that.
It just drives me crazy. 30 seconds remaining.
Um, so like I said,
how many people here would vote for a rec center even if it was 300%?
So I hope you pass this. Get us some officers out there to help
us out. Thank you.
Denver Dorrell.
Hi. I didn't come up here prepared.
Life, liberty, and pursuit of happiness. The American dream.
That's what I've always wanted. Eagle Mountain was the
first place I was able to actually achieve that.
And I'm gonna tell you right now, I'm stressed out, panicked,
because that American dream is about to turn into a nightmare.
I am in a single Income household.
Yeah, I make good money, but, you know, I got everything
else going on. Um, I don't think anybody here would argue
setting money aside for the Sheriff's Department, first responders,
because, you know, my family alone has benefited so
much from them. You know, with my 4-year-old daughter who
has more flight hours in a Life Flight than the pilot himself.
My son, who was shot in his neck, you know, right before
Christmas, one of the sheriff's deputies stuck
her finger in my son's neck to keep him from
bleeding out. We ain't got no problem with
setting money aside for the sheriff's department or first responders.
But That, you know,
coming at us, you know, hey, we're going to increase taxes 5,
10, 15%. You know, we can
understand that. But 220%?
I'm living off of credit cards.
I'm sure there's a lot of other families that are doing the same. Fixed incomes,
single-income household. This is going to
break me. I won't be able to afford it.
And we ended up getting kicked out of American Homes
for Rent because of the incident with my son, even though we
had no idea, you know, we couldn't prevent that.
That was an incident that came from a whole other town.
Yeah, we got kicked out, and by the grace of God, he gave
us our own home to move into. But now that's about
to be taken away, and I ain't got nowhere else to go.
So I hope that y'all don't have your minds already set
up on approving this, because it's going to put not only me
and my family, but I'm sure a lot of other families out. 30 seconds remaining.
Thank y'all for listening.
Mark Cookston. Cookston.
Good evening, and thank you, uh, City Council and
everybody that works for the city. This is— I wouldn't want to be in your
chair. This is going to be very, very difficult for, for you as,
as it is for for all of us. In 2018,
I was in the hospital for 5 weeks
and life-flighted down to the University of Utah. I lost my pancreas and automatically
became diabetic and automatically
became tied to Utah. We— I was life-flighted
down from Idaho, and because
of that, we have to We have to live down here in— or
I should say we get to live down here in Utah.
We chose Eagle Mountain because my wife and
I grew up in small towns in Idaho
and liked the small-town values. And we saw
that in Eagle Mountain. We moved in,
you know, 5 years ago this coming Thanksgiving.
And we had just passed 40,000 people here. Now we're
closing in on 80,000 people. We liked
the vibe of the community. I will say that never
in my lifetime did I ever think that I would ever be purchasing a home
for half a million dollars. But coming from Idaho and,
you know, coming to Utah was an eye-opening
experience. We chose Eagle Mountain because
it was affordable. We were told by the previous
mayor and then Councilman Gray that,
oh no, we won't have to raise taxes because we've got
large companies that are going to be paying
a large, or footing a large part of
the taxes down the road. Little did I
know that down the road is 20 years, long after I'll be dead.
So that really— that argument was kind of a
moot point for us. I'm on Social Security.
Last year I got a raise of $27 a month.
My God, I thought the rainbow had fallen upon
my house. Then the
county of Utah raised my taxes
$250 last year. 30 seconds remaining. And that was all gone.
This year we've got this one that is
proposed. It's going to be wiped out.
Whatever increase that I, that I get is going to be wiped out.
What am I supposed to do? Where am I supposed to go?
This was the most affordable place for us to live.
I'm here, health reasons, guys.
Where am I supposed to go? What am I supposed to do? Tighten my
belt, I was told. Your time is up. Thank you. Have you guys tightened your
Tracy Perretta.
All righty.
This isn't
my first meeting. You all know we've come to these meetings and there's
been literally nobody here. It's an absolute ghost town.
Okay, you guys all fit in this City Hall perfectly.
You don't need this one time you go to raise taxes and we
get people in here for a meeting. You are fine
in the building you're in. You don't need to build the new, uh, what do
you call it, in— it's the new,
new base camp on the city
page you did back in March of '25. You put
up all these plans of everything you guys want to build and spend money on.
I don't know where you're getting this money, but it shouldn't be from taxes.
Because I came here and I sat right over
there in a meeting and I opposed the new data center going in, the QST.
And I was told by you, Melissa, personally, and Jared, both told
me afterward, oh, this is such a great thing. The reason we're passing
this is because our taxes are going to go down. They're going to
be so low with all the revenue we're going to get from the data centers
coming in that your taxes are going to go to almost zero.
Explain that to me personally, Melissa, because I will spend the rest of
my time getting you out of office because you lied to me.
Same for Jared. If, if our taxes don't go down to almost zero,
why are you raising them so high? We don't need a rec center.
You know, the last thing you need to do is when money is tight is
say, oh, I need to add on to my house because I get a big
group of people at Christmas. It's not logical.
You've got to spend your money wisely. When everybody
here is tightening their budgets, you guys are building new Eagle
Mountain city signs because the rocks were deteriorating.
You know, I left one weekend, came back, and I noticed you put up new
street signs. What was that price? $10,000. Your new street signs that you put
up were a total of— I mean, the city mount— Eagle Mountain
City sign out there at Cory Bee Ride, that was probably a
$200,000 project or more.
You put in a new set of signs that were
on that page. It says that they were wayfinding sign
project to have Eagle Mountain and make
it more cohesive with their signage. And that was $50,000.
If you tighten your budget everywhere like every single other family has
to, you could make up the money you need for
the police and the fire department. 30 seconds remaining. You don't need
to take our taxes and raise them for something that is just frivolous.
We don't need a rec center. We don't need a new town city hall.
Tighten your budget and figure it out. 'Cause I was told that taxes are
going to go down with all the new data centers, and that's not what you're
doing. Thank you.
Steve Pereda.
Hi, welcome. Thanks for hearing me.
My wife just got done speaking about the data centers. I'm going to speak about
them too. We spoke about them about a year ago.
We took the math of what the tax revenue was going to be. We divided
it by the number of households in Eagle Mountain, and we came up with about
$50 a month towards each household throughout the city
of Eagle Mountain. So $50 a month is $600 a
year. Now you're proposing a 220% increase that
by your own documentation says around $314
a year increase. So we have a $900-plus
differentiation in what your word was a
year ago because, well, oh, we, we need
to, we need to allow the data centers. The data centers are good because they're
going to bring all this tax revenue in and it's going to reduce your taxes.
A year later were $900 the other direction?
I'd love to see somebody's math on that as to how that math got screwed
up. So unless you guys fix this— I mean, this was prior to the mayoral
race— all of these people are— the
vast majority of these people, I won't say all, are pretty unhappy. So when
unhappy people go to the voting booths, All of
you get to go find new jobs.
Okay?
If my home budget was short, the first thing
I'd do as a conservative is I'd figure out how to reduce my spending.
I don't just go figure out where I can get more money.
There's also been talk of no transparency. You guys are not giving us
all of the information. Nope, just trust us.
But then your stories are changing, so how can we trust you?
That doesn't work. Inconsistent statements.
We need to itemize budget. We need to quit spending money like
drunken sailors on a port call, okay? Um,
running out and, and, you know, buying signs.
Uh, oh, let's get a rec center. Let's, let's build a new city hall.
What's wrong with this one?
Instead of looking at the entire budget and making educated,
informed decisions, you guys are taking the easy way out.
That's the bottom line. Where's the easy money we can get?
All we have to do is increase our property taxes by 220% and
we can cover all these other expenses we want to do. Please continue.
You were elected to make hard decisions. Make those
hard decisions. Thank you.
Charlotte Dukos.
Charlotte Dukos. I'm going to join
Jeff and Matt in making
some comments that are maybe a little bit different. I've lived here for 26 years.
Years and been involved in the city for the majority of that time,
if not all of it. And over— for
the last over a year, I've attended almost all city
council meetings, missed a couple for other things.
And in attending those meetings, there's a lot of the
questions that are being presented here tonight that have been answered, and I
want to acknowledge that. The budget is online,
line item, in a 200-page document.
And so that is available. All of these projects, everything that
we're talking about tonight has been talked about in city meetings. And so I want
to thank you for actually having those discussions in public meetings for
those that were there. Eagle Mountain
has run lean since its beginning. We have employees doing the job
of 2 to 3 people, probably more in some cases. We have offices
renting space all over the city because they don't fit in this one.
We have projects that we have funded but don't have personnel to complete, and so
they stay undone. We have complaints all over the city of things
that are not maintained, things that have been promised but have not been done,
and we don't have the personnel to complete it
because we don't have the money to pay them. And We have
waited too long to address these shortfalls. They should have been addressed years
ago in a graduated manner,
a little at a time, but that did not happen. And we
can't keep kicking the can down the road. At some point, something has to be
done, and I applaud you for taking the time to do that now.
That having been said, I do think the
communication could probably have improved. I think most of you agree with
that now as well. And I do think
that a more moderate approach would
be good. It's not too late to do that, and I think a smaller percentage
might be good. I don't think it's going to be a percentage that most people
like. I still think it needs to be a significant one, but maybe
not 220. We would go from being one
of the lowest tax rates in the
area to the 3rd highest. And I think that maybe something a little
more moderate would be a good way to start. And maybe we decrease that
amount a little bit. 30 seconds remaining. I also would encourage you
to put a policy in place that I do not believe is existing right now
where we review this yearly or every other year and do
graduated increases as they are needed. We need to stop being afraid to
balance our budget on a yearly basis so
that these big jumps don't have to happen. And that is my— the conclusion of
my comments. Thank you so much. much for your service.
Michael Valentini.
Hello, my name is Michael Valentini.
I moved out here almost 2 years ago to the date. Um,
we moved out here because it, uh, gave us an opportunity that
we didn't have in Lehi for our children. Uh, One thing
I'd like to say is that the data centers,
my question for you is what tax breaks did the data centers
get? So I've been a union member of Local 140 Plumbers
and Pipefitters here in Utah for 29 years. I work at
the data centers. I've worked at Facebook and QTS since 2000.
Okay, that's my question.
QTS has 3 buildings going on now. A 4th
is being built now. The 5th is coming. From what I
understand, there'll be 6 additional buildings at QTS.
Facebook has 5 buildings now, the 3 ECO—
or the 3 original buildings,
2 additional buildings that went in just previously,
and they are building 2 more buildings out there now. So what tax
breaks do they get? As more people come in building these,
that brings revenue into the economy.
Am I wrong to say that there's 6,000, 4,000 to 6,000
construction workers between Facebook and QTS building those facilities?
They bring money into this community every day at the gas
stations, the grocery stores, everything. So that
generates money for this community. Okay, we do
need to have police, a police force out here, the first responders.
Those are very important, but we also need to be able
to live. There are a lot of communities that are being built in here that
have, what do they call them, the ADUs, apartments in the basements.
So that shows that people that are buying these houses are supplementing income
by having renters in their basements.
Okay, what's the average income of of
Eagle Mountain, 78,000? What's the average cost of a house?
What's the average cost of that house? And then
you want to increase our taxes by 220%.
So if we haven't had a tax increase on
our property tax in 10 or 15 years, why wasn't
this budgeted in at 5%, 2% a year over
the last 15 years? That's kind of piss-poor planning.
It really is. Sorry to say it. So, 30 seconds remaining.
You got it. I work 60, 70 hours a week, not because
I like to, but because I try to provide for my family so
that we can have the house we live in, the vehicles that we drive,
and take vacations, put food on our table. When these property taxes go up,
and they're going to go up on residents and commercial— commercial is going raise their
cost of living, their prices at the grocery stores,
at the convenience stores, everywhere. And it's going to affect everybody in
this room, not just 220%. Your time
is up. Thank you. Hi, my name is Elba
Maria Perez.
And pretty much everything that I was going to say has been said,
so I don't want to repeat it. The only thing that I have not heard
is that I don't hope,
but I pray that you guys really listen
to what is being said. Each one of you,
really listen, because people are suffering and you're
choking us by these big increases
in taxes. I really
pray that you will listen to what has been said this evening.
That's all.
Walter Peterson.
Hi, good evening. I'm Walter Peterson. I've lived here for about 3 years,
uh, and we just were able to buy a home here in Eagle Mountain,
um, which we're really excited about. I'm a little less excited with the 220%
increase, um, and a lot of my thoughts have
been said. Um, a more moderate view of
this or increase would be appreciated here.
I'm also extraordinarily wary about the school district coming
in next year as a teacher That is something that worries me
with that, where I probably won't have a pay increase for those few years where
they're trying to get going. And so having
maybe a 100%, 130%, I don't
know, a smaller number increase would be greatly appreciated if you do have
time to make that change. I think that you've
heard that from the other people that have spoken this evening,
but We appreciate what you do, and we hope that you listen tonight.
Thank you.
Jacob Moore.
Thank you to the City Council and Mayor Gray. My name is Jacob Moore.
Not intending to make a comment tonight, and I initially strongly opposed this
increase. However, I recently received more clear information
to the city's purpose and why the drastic 221%
increase. The state is planning on passing a law this next
legislative session limiting any city to a 5% increase,
so Eagle Mountain City has to do it now or will be restricted by
state policies because Utah's revenue Not
rate-driven, the massive growth has not increased the city's tax revenue
because the rate is lowered to account for the growth, which keeps the revenue roughly
the same. That's something that I've frequently heard: that we've
had so much growth, we should have more money. But that's apparently
not the way it works here in Utah. It's important to understand
that the 221% increase applies only to the city's portion of
your property tax bill, not your. Total property taxes. For the
average homeowner, that translates to roughly a 12% increase
in the overall property tax, not 221%.
The city wants the property tax increase so our full sheriff's contract is
paid for by the property taxes— been said multiple times tonight— not
having to pull those millions from the city's general fund. I've been told that the
funds freed up— the funds freed up in the general fund would be used for
infrastructure and other public safety improvements.
If that's true, then the messaging from the city has
not been as misleading or dishonest as a lot of people are saying.
I believe it would go a long way if the city council and mayor would
explain as much as possible exactly what the freed-up general fund money would be used
for, as others have requested.
I do believe it's unfortunate that the city's hand is being forced by the state
legislature, which wants the step into city policies and tell cities what they are and
are not allowed to do with their tax rates.
I'm not opposed anymore, but I believe a smaller increase, as many
others have said, is a better solution than the proposed increase.
And I did want to add that I
encourage Eagle Mountain citizens to ask the state legislature to
change the property tax to a rate-driven system. So as the
population increases, our revenue does as well. Instead of the current
system, it is forcing the city council's hand to increase our
taxes to increase the revenue. And then
I do also believe that it's— there's
been unintentional confusion. 30 seconds remaining.
And it's not the same as dishonesty as many are claiming
tonight. I feel like a lot of emotions are clouding judgment.
I wanna thank you for all you do. I can't imagine being in your shoes,
and I'm glad I'm not. Have a great night.
We do have a form filled out by Garrett Houghter, who does not want to
make a verbal comment, but did note down, I want to echo what Charlotte Duco
said. And then our next one is Jason Rasmussen.
Good afternoon. Jason Rasmussen. I've been a resident here for
3 years. First of all, I want to thank all of you for the
efforts that you make, and I want to thank our
public first responders for all
the things that they do to, to keep our city safe.
I think A lot of the frustration that
we're hearing is essentially what you did is you
held up a marble that said public safety and you put it
under a cup and then you had 3 other cups. You flipped
them around, you pulled up the cups, and what you
revealed was a card that said 210% tax increase.
And so we're a little bit confused how this public safety
marble is replaced with a, a 210% or 220%
tax increase. Um, and I know that a lot of people have
already expressed, um, that we just need more transparency about,
like, how the monies would be spent. We need more
transparency about how money could be reclaimed.
We need more transparency about how money could be saved.
How you can retrench in ways. So it's essentially just what
can you do to kind of let us know how the money is going to
be spent? Are there other sources of revenue? And how can you
retrench in places that you can retrench? And I
would add just one additional item.
I know that a lot of the data centers that have been built in
Eagle Mountain have been built with, you know,
tax breaks of up to 77%.
$150 million, and that's
a large percentage more than the $6 million revenue
that you're trying to get. And it seems in some ways
like you gave a break to artificial intelligence at
the expense of all the human intelligences in this
room and in our community. So thank you.
Thank you.
Joy Rasmussen.
So in 2018, Facebook got
tax breaks on their property taxes that
was pretty hefty, and some of you were involved
in that. It was $150 million. in property tax incentives
that they are not paying for, what, 40 years? So that's
money the city could have been using all this time that you took away from
us. And then 2021, more data centers
were given $77 million in property tax incentives,
again for Meta. QTS is currently building more
data centers that are for Meta and Google, and they
have also been given tax breaks on sales tax. So the city
has made a choice. Do we tax data centers to
build AI to take our jobs and take our children's jobs and
then tax the residents, or do we not do that? And you
have made those choices. Now, to say that you're paying the price for previous politicians—
most of you have been here in city politics for many years. You have voted.
Last year's budget, you did not increase property taxes, but you added
public safety officers, and you bragged about it on your website. I took the screenshot
tonight. Somehow you managed to do it before, but now you're saying you can't anymore.
I have done some research, and guess what? When you add data centers to your
city, public infrastructure costs go up. So somebody
in this, in this town, Alex Washburn, has done a GRAMA request and asked
you guys for information about why you're doing this and where you're spending the money
and what capital projects this is going to go towards, because that's what it's for.
And his request was denied, and you made him— you're going to charge
him a huge fee he can't afford. And then you met with him and somehow
got him to think it was necessary. But here's the thing. We have a lot
more houses in Eagle Mountain than we did before. So even if the amount that
you can charge per house has not increased, the number of houses has increased.
So you still have more revenue with the increase in citizens. This is absolutely
to fund the data centers. There's an electrician in Eagle Mountain that has messaged me.
He works at the data centers. He said that QTS wants to put 27
data centers in Eagle Mountain. There's already about 7 approved.
And that's— he said if he lived here, he would be upset.
He said he's not going to stay because the energy costs and the water costs
are going to skyrocket. He doesn't understand why the residents are not upset. The city
has been trying to put nuclear reactors in the city for the data
centers. All of you in this room need to know this and wake up.
We need to fight this like Box Elder County. Thank you. because we are already
paying the price. These data centers are getting the break and we're getting dorked
over. 30 seconds remaining. People can't afford it. There's a
lady I know who messaged me. She is elderly. Her husband has dementia
and Parkinson's. They are on fixed incomes. And she said,
our house is paid for, but we cannot afford this property tax increase. My husband's
gonna have to go into a care center for $5,000 a month.
This is going to bankrupt us. You need to think about those people and not
do this. This is totally inappropriate. There needs to be more time. and more public
disclosure about where this money is really going and what infrastructure you're putting it towards,
what capital projects, and give— listen to the people.
Your time is up. Thank you.
Michael Carey.
Michael Carey. I'm going to read this. Mayor and members of the City Council,
thank you for your service and for the opportunity to speak tonight. I want
to begin by saying that I support public safety. I believe our deputies and first
responders deserve the resources they need to protect our growing community.
As Eagle Mountain continues to grow, it is reasonable to expect
that the cost of providing those services will grow as well.
My concern is not whether we should invest in public safety. My concern is
the size of the proposed increase and whether residents have been given the
complete financial picture. The city's public information states that every dollar of
the proposed increase will go toward funding the sheriff's contract and expanding
public safety. At the same time, the city's public— published materials also
discuss other financial pressures facing Eagle Mountain, including rapid
population growth, inflation, increased road maintenance, parks infrastructure,
and other essential city services. If public
safety is the immediate use of these new tax dollars, I understand that.
But if broader budget pressure— pressures are also contributing to
the need for this increase, I believe residents deserve a transparent discussion
about those challenges as well. An informed public is better able to support
difficult decisions. I would also encourage the City Council to consider a phased
approach instead of implementing the full increase in a single year.
A 3 to 5 year graduated plan would still provide additional funding
for public safety while giving families time to adjust to higher
property taxes during a period when many are already experiencing
rising costs in housing, insurance, groceries,
and utilities. A 3 to 5— sorry,
a phased approach would also allow the city to measure results along the way.
Before each phase, the City Council could publicly report measurable
outcomes such as improvements in emergency response times, changes in
deputy workload and staffing ratios, growth in calls for service,
progress toward clearly defined public safety goals, Whether growth-related
revenues or operational efficiencies have reduced the need for future tax
increases. I would also respectfully ask the council to explain
why 7 additional deputies represent the appropriate staffing level
and what objective analysis supports that recommendation. Understanding the
data behind the proposal will help public confidence. Finally,
I encourage the council to continue exploring every available option
to reduce the burden on taxpayers, including efficiencies
within city operations, careful prioritization of spending,
and identifying growth-related revenue sources before asking
residents to absorb significant increases in property taxes.
Please conclude. I believe Eagle Mountain residents are willing to invest in their community when
they understand the need and have confidence in the plan. Transparent, measurable, and great—
a gradual approach can strengthen that trust while still meeting city's responsibilities,
keep our community safe. Thank you for your time and service and
for your consideration. Camille Gardner.
I don't see Camille. We'll add her paper to the record.
Please remember you represent those who elected you. We don't need additional police, nor all
the other projects you think we do. We want economy at the
city. Like Stuart Adams, we will vote you out
if you vote for this increase. Additionally, we don't need Ranches Parkway widened.
We need a right-hand turn lane.
KB Bergenson.
Good evening. K.B. Bergeson. I've lived here about 3 years.
Before that, I lived in California and Washington, and I moved here to
get away from those places, so I was glad to be here. But I
am a 7-year Army veteran, and I also retired
from law enforcement. I worked for a sheriff's office.
So I have deep respect and am grateful for the services
they do provide us. Thank you. And I'm grateful, you know, for their
service and what they, you know, do for us. I'm 75
years old, and I live with my daughter and her
family. I came here to join with them so we could be on a budget
and survive the economy. I'm on a fixed budget. I'm retired.
With that in mind, I don't think that we need a 220%
increase in property tax. to support
law enforcement and what they're doing. I emailed
all of you, you know, asking you about this,
and I did receive one response from Craig, and I appreciate
that. I thought it was very insightful. I quote, he said,
also, I don't think we need— that we'll end up needing
a 220% increase. In the past few weeks, we've been diving into the numbers,
and I think the city can get by with a small smaller number than 220%.
I'm not sure what number. It will still be a large increase,
but not 220%. A few comments I'll give you since
I've been on the council for 3.5 years. We anticipate—
next year we anticipate revenue— that data center
revenues will take a jump. We need an increase to help with additional needs.
If next year doesn't bring enough data center revenue, I'm sure 3 and 4 years
we'll see that money coming in. Further, we should have Smith
development online by then as well, and I think there's a realistic possibility to revisit
that increase. I think if that's the case, if that's
in mind, we should take a measured approach to any increase right now.
There's other things that can be done for law enforcement, too. I know that there's
other places I've been, they've had a citizens patrol where they have
seniors volunteer to take a workload off of deputies.
That can be done, and maybe that can be looked into. There's a lot of
other things that be done and looked into to help with law enforcement without,
you know, budgeting huge amounts of money. I'm on a fixed
balanced budget, and I think that the city should also be on a fixed balanced
budget. You need to take the funds that you make and use them wisely
and determine what takes priority and spend that money— 30 seconds remaining.
—according to those priorities, and other things should not be done until the money
comes in and it can be spent accordingly. Thank you very much.
Steve Campbell.
Mayor Gray, councilmen, Councilman Wright,
I'm a 20-year resident. I'm going to make this really simple. I think
we've been here long enough and everyone has said a lot, but I have a
question. The other day I just happened to hear that
the federal government Office of Management and Budget
provides grants to cities. A grant is free money. I mean, it's not
free, it's our tax dollars to the federal government. They will
provide grants to cities to upgrade public
safety, police departments, this type of thing.
I wasn't aware of this. I don't know if you folks are aware
or not. If you're not, it bears looking into.
Yes. If you have, great. I don't
know the process for applying for a grant.
I do know they're available. My daughter gets them all the time from
the federal government for disadvantaged children in the school systems.
So just point of interest. Anyway,
good to see you, Brett. Good to see you all. Thank you very much.
Shedrick D. Shermond.
Feel free to correct me if I'm not close. Okay. Yeah,
for the record, Cedric DeChermond. Um, I was going to write this with the help
of AI, but the Wi-Fi wouldn't connect, and I thought maybe it's a little too
ironic to not just speak from the heart. So my
wife and I moved to Eagle Mountain a little over 3 years ago due to
the prospect of affordable living, safety,
well-planned growth strategy, and to raise our own family.
I've worked and lived all across this country. This is the first home I've
ever bought, and I'm proud of it. As a young family,
our budget is tight, and our options are weighed when we spend our hard-earned
money. We want to start a family and often deliberate how.
I won't explain what it is you're doing in economic principles.
Plenty of us have already done that already, and frankly, should already know.
Taxes and costs often go up and rarely go down.
I worry that you already know that too. The proposed tax
increase, or upon its original inception, does not even begin
to address concerns regarding the following: future impacts due to the new school
district— and my wife is a teacher— um, current shortfalls in infrastructure
and future growth of infrastructure needs. The irony in the
truth and transparency is that as taxpayers, we are seeing a limited
view you into the current stewardship of the use of our current tax revenue.
If you are a poor steward now, you will be a worse steward with
more. But as a general populace, we cannot contend
with what we do not know and what you are failing to accurately disclose.
We as citizens can't keep up with all of the wavering of priorities
and promises being potentially broken. We can nonetheless see
that you are ostensibly lying.
Are all of the developers, outside contractors, and multibillion-dollar
industries that operate and profit off of our city paying their fair share?
We all know the answer. You want to hold our feet to the fire but
won't stand against them. Can you account for the impact of this proposed
tax increase in terms of hungry mouths, missed payments,
and ultimately families no longer being able to call Eagle Mountain their
home? I don't think you can. You can't share the budget you have,
and you can't show the forecast for the projects you want. A lot of people
blame young kids for the hoodrat behavior and damage we see growing around here.
I blame parenting. Can we account for the lack of parental guidance
as a result of them having to work harder to pay for this fund?
Are we operating in a banana republic? I and others helped
elect you in those chairs on the principles of family values, economic frugality,
and fiscal conservatism. Is this tyranny? We have enough of
that going on in our country and in our world. This shitty council should reject
those ends. I would request that you consider a motion to defer this
vote until you can better communicate your past decisions, future, future intents,
and your clearly stated budget objectives to the community that deserves to hear a transparent
truth of the situation. Thank you.
Isaac Gardner.
He did provide a written comment in opposition to the tax increase. We will
add it to the For the record, Daniel Lamb— Lob.
Feel
free to correct me if I'm incorrect on your name.
For some reason it's always Lamb. It's Lob.
Anyway, thank you for having this opportunity for
us to speak. I'm here not because I want to be, like a
lot of other people. We have a lot of other things we want to be
doing. But we're so against this increase, that's why we're
here. We can't, we don't feel that we can afford this.
Transparency has been discussed. Like, I just agree with all the other comments that have
been made. Like, that's probably the best way to sum it up.
Yeah, right now we're not buying it. We're just, we don't buy what
you guys are proposing. We don't agree to it. That's why I'm here is to,
you know, make my voice heard. Don't agree to it.
There's—it's not the best thing,
and I hate to say this. Like I'm not trying to be offensive, but the
citizens, like for myself, I will try to make sure you're not reelected again.
I will. If this passes, just know it
may be your last term. So anyway, we appreciate
everything else you're doing that's that's positive, and not trying to be negative here,
but we really don't want this increase.
And if it goes through and you pass it, it's a death knell.
Pretty sure about that.
Shawna Clark.
Is that right? Shawna?
Okay.
I wasn't going to get up today because I'm not very eloquent and
there's been a lot of people that have talked very well.
But the more I sat there, the more I just wanted to make sure that
I'm just not a person sitting in the audience observing, that you know how I
feel. In September of 1998, my family
moved out here. So next month will be 28 years that I've been
out here. We moved out here because we couldn't afford to live anywhere else.
I raised my kids out here. I became single out here through divorce.
And I've been able to stay here. Thank you. My youngest daughter and
her 4 kids, age range in age from 3 to
9, live with me as well. She stays home to take care of the
kids, and I make $16 an hour.
I've heard it said about the impact fees.
The homes being built, more money that way.
I just feel like with the tax breaks that other big
businesses get and then being scammed out of the money,
I feel like me as a $16 an hour person am being
asked to pay that. It is not my fault.
Not that it's your fault, not all of it.
But I feel like this is a huge ask
of you guys. Not ask, you're not asking us, you're just gonna do it.
I've had to refinance my house a few times to get my
ex-husband off, to get money out because I couldn't afford things.
And the last time was to lower my interest
rate. So even though I've been out here for almost 28 years, I still owe
25 years on my house. It's not like I can save
many other places. So I really wish you would think about
how this affects the small people.
Dax Steadily.
I do not see him present. Also in opposition to the tax
increase. We will add his comment to the record. Colton Hart.
I do not see him in opposition to the tax increase.
We'll add his comment to the record. Sadie Hart,
also opposition to the tax increase.
We'll get that one added as well.
Melissa Gordette.
She states, please don't raise our taxes. I do not see her in person.
We'll add her comment to the record. Kristen Meyer.
Good evening, Mayor and City Council members. My name is Kristen Meyer and
I'm a resident of Eagle Mountain. I'm here tonight to urge you to vote no
on the proposed tax increase. Let me state why.
Roughly $1.5 million is allocated to the Utah County Sheriff's contract.
I don't have an issue with that. My issue is
with the remaining amount that has been— it hasn't been
allocated clearly enough. We wanna know exactly how
it will be spent. Thank you.
These are public funds and we need transparency, not vague line items.
Second, how did we get here? The podcast indicated
that a failed bill from the previous legislative session may have capped— it
might have capped future tax increases. Fair enough.
But your response, along with other cities, seems to be that we should raise
taxes now before the state can cap us in the future.
And the bill failed. And what is the response? As a city,
you knew we were growing. You approved the development.
You approved the growth. And instead of having the common sense
to plan for the roads and the infrastructure and all the needs that
we require, you failed to act.
Third, we are in an affordability crisis. It's a crisis
fueled in part by greedy corporations. And the politicians who
too often put the powerful interests ahead of the hardworking Americans.
I propose you lower the tax to cover only the sheriff's contract.
And before these words fall on deaf ears, think about
the people you represent. Think about the senior living on a fixed income.
Think about the mother wondering how she's going to make it to the next paycheck.
Think about the people who have experienced the embarrassment of having their credit
card declined. Although we do not have the power to decide
how you vote, we do have the power to decide who votes in these
seats tomorrow.
And I ask that you earn our trust. Vote no on this proposal
as it stands, and we ask for greater transparency.
Thank you.
Cheryl Carr.
Good evening. My name is Cheryl Carr.
We bought our land in 1998. We built
our home in 2004. Been here for 22 years.
I'm 71 years old. Thank you. My husband is 76.
Our property has more than doubled since
we've been here. Our income has not.
That value is not realized unless we
sell our home. I want to read President
Donald Trump has— he may
be federal, but this is his view. He has proposed eliminating
local property taxes for homeowners aged
65 and older who have fully paid off their mortgages.
He characterized property taxes as a form of perpetual rent
that prevents seniors on fixed incomes from From truly
owning their own homes. Relief for
fixed incomes— supporters state the plan protects older
Americans from raising housing insurance and valuation costs.
Aging in place— advocates argue it helps retirees
keep their lifelong homes instead of being forced to
move. I will tell you, if this
passes, we will have to sell and we
will have to move.
I know there needs to be more money.
And the people who are coming to Eagle Mountain create
more traffic on the roads. We've all seen that. So what
is the answer? What would you like to see happen?
It's, it's a tough one, but I think that the impact fees
need to be raised. I don't know what they are, but I do know
that this problem is a result
of more people moving here, and they
need to pay for that impact. And so
that would be my request. That you look at those impact fees
and see where things can be shifted.
30 seconds remaining. I do thank you for your service
and for your time. Thank you.
Roger Laird.
Sorry, I'm not exactly Just as nice as everybody, but my day
started at 2:30 this morning, and I didn't
get off until 4:30 today, and I rushed down to be here
for this. 220% is
rather asinine. I probably
more than anybody in here support police officers and EMS
because I spent the entirety of my young adulthood in
EMS. I've been shot at. I've been stabbed.
I've been shoulder to shoulder with police fighting.
And it's not fun. Well, it was, but— But
probably none of you guys have been shot at or stabbed or been
in those situations or watched people die or drug a
wounded police officer that was shot because some gangbanger wanted some
clout while we were on the side of a road at a call.
I work very hard for my money. We moved here because it
was affordable, it was a nice community, and it's a little bit a
ways from it all. You can't
tell me, you can't convince me 220% is
reasonable. Some of you are real estate agents. That is a negative
at asset that you're trying to sell people.
And if you're the kind of real estate agent that sells negative assets
to people, I would probably say you're not exactly an ethical real estate
agent. I did real estate, one of the many things I've
done, besides EMS paramedic, crane operator,
real estate, and mortgage loan officer.
So, The fact that you guys can't
articulate where all that's going other than you're selling it under the guise of
helping the police officers, which is a good thing. I don't think anybody's opposed
to giving them help and the EMS any help.
But those data centers, which I've
worked on, I've been on a crane in there for 16 hours one
day. The fact, and it's
you, Oh, the tax breaks you
give them could be paying for all of this. And, and the,
the bullcrap part is you guys know it, but you
give them all these tax breaks. And then all these builders that want to come
in, and we're getting more revenue from taxes on that. Again,
you know it. I'm not saying you guys— that things weren't mismanaged
in the past, but you can fix it by simply cutting costs and
stop giving all these tax breaks. There's 7 more
buildings going in there. I know that because I work there.
Please do better.
Budget like we all do.
Thank you.
Zeke, Zeke Magdalio.
Hi, my name is Zeke Magdaleno. I've been here about 7 years. I'm kind of
neutral, gentleman right here, uh, between the data
centers and a resident because I build them and I
know what they cost. I know what they bring in, and I have to be
careful what I say so I have a job tomorrow.
So, but I, I'm finding myself
not understanding Because I feel it's a duty to—
even though I could lose my job if I'm not careful,
I have to say something for all these people here,
including myself, that might not be able to afford a home.
I was able to, as a single dad, afford a
house on a single income, raise my children, and I'll be
perfectly honest, I hated it in the middle of the desert. I couldn't stand it.
But we've come a long way in 6 years.
So I want to bring some transparency for
the people behind me on the
data centers. And by
the time QTS is done— I can say QTS, we all know it's signs out
there— they're predicted that Eagle Mountain will be the biggest
data center campuses for them in
the world. Not United States, the world.
Let that sink in.
So if we're allowing these data centers to be built
and we get— we are getting them tax breaks, which I understand,
we want them to come here and build these data centers, but isn't that supposed
to help these people, us, out in the long run? That's what I
thought. That's what they're supposed to do. And I know how many they're planning on
building. Honestly, we shouldn't have to pay taxes for our
lifetime. These guys have so much money. I know what they bring
in when they rent these data centers, and it's
insane. It's insane how much money that, that these,
these people have that are building these data centers.
So I'm confused on why
220% Why are we paying anything? I,
I maybe I got here late, so I'm sorry if this
was talked about earlier. But being that I'm building them
and I'm kind of neutral, I just don't see— and I'm,
I, you know, obviously I'm a community member paying my mortgage.
That's insane. I think that comes out to like $300 more,
I think, a month, something like that. That's crazy. But anyways,
just to stick up for the data centers a little bit, The ones we're building
are closed systems. They don't use water like the other ones, just letting
you know. They do in the beginning, but they're closed. They're not evaporative.
That's Facebook. I worked on that one too. That's all I gotta say.
Megan Streeter.
Does it start when I speak? Hi,
I'm a delegate and precinct chair in Eagle
Mountain and have interacted with several of my city council members. Nice to
see you, Brett. Nice to see you, Melissa. I know you two and find you
to be reasonable, logical humans. And with that said, I do feel like we are
missing a mark here. I do feel that way, especially with the
sheriffs. I do not dislike the sheriffs, appreciate you,
but I do think in the current state we're in, I mean, I think it's
a good idea to invest with them in the current state we're in, but I
do feel that we need our own department.
And with that said,
renting is worse than owning, and I do feel like we are making a bad
decision by renting the sheriffs. I don't think it's an investment for our city.
Aside from that, I do believe we are missing the opportunity to negotiate with data
centers, and he pretty much set me up for success when he was speaking.
I have a unique perspective as I have rented land from many of the farmers
out there by the data centers. I have watched as these farmers have been cornered.
I've watched as they have been bullied. I've watched even their own cows
be poisoned. And we're not— I mean, there's so many stories you guys
don't know about, and you haven't been out there talking to the farmers. And if
you've ignored them, then you would know what's been going on.
One of those guys out there, he leased his land for $100,000
a month. And then when he's done leasing, he will be bought out.
And then just one QTS manager gets
$500,000 for 10 months. We need to stop acting like we need the data
centers and start acting like they need us, as they do. We have the land
and the water to provide space for them. Data centers are being banned all over
the nation and in the world, and we know this. It's a hot topic right
now. They need us, period. And they have the money to give us
the full $7 million you need for the 220 increase. I guarantee that you
can negotiate that. Thank you. I have faith in you. I absolutely believe that you
guys could do this because they need us. Eagle Mountain's special. We're unique.
And aside from that, I love this city, and I hope
we can manage these situations in a way that allows us to move forward
in a small-town ideal since a lot of these people moved here
for that, and I did as well. And I absolutely hate your job. I'm sure
it's horrible, but I really think that we're missing the mark, and I really hope
we can do better. Thank you. do something better. I really do.
Tony Castillo.
Tony Castillo. You know,
everybody knows who we are. We own a roofing company.
COVID hit us hard. I saw prices
go up every month, my material cost every month,
10% here, 10% there. I'd go to my wife,
we gotta raise our prices. And this
is after my suppliers were chewing me out because they were
hearing from competitors how I was undercutting them.
And I said, is it affecting your bottom line? I'm still buying
from you guys. The only difference is I'm not getting rich
like those guys are.
This year, I'm not talking COVID, we had about a 60% price increase.
60% just in one year.
And I got smart, didn't change suppliers,
just negotiated.
This year we had about a 30% price increase because of the war.
I watched my— I'm going to use this to be upfront, guys. My per bundle
price to operate my company for
one brand is $150 a bundle.
That was after the price increase that I got.
And I went back and I said, I can't operate like this.
And, you know, a lot of you guys are my customers.
I had Charlotte ask me, her daughter asked me, how the heck are you $5,000
less than these other companies, but you're doing more?
I want your business. I know my numbers.
I'll go back to my suppliers and renegotiate.
You guys get to renegotiate. Yeah. I support the tax increase.
220%— I mean, I'll be honest with you, it's very shocking.
Can you imagine if I raised my prices 220%?
I mean, Craig, you had a customer beat me up over
the quote I gave him, even a repair. I had to walk away from
it. Had I done it, it would have opened me into a multimillion-dollar community.
Thank you. But my values are a lot worth more than that.
Elections are coming up again.
At the end of the day, guys, do what's right. 30 seconds remaining. A lot
of us can't afford to eat. And I was like,
I'm wondering, you know, can I afford to buy a cow this year if
the rate goes up? 'Cause that's the first thing I'm gonna be cutting. So thanks,
guys. Appreciate y'all.
I have Melanie Castillo who chooses not to make a verbal comment. And while
she states, while I support an increase and see its need,
she's interested to hear from each member of the council the top 3 capital projects.
And she's seen the list and wants to know what's
important to the council members on that one. And then we do have,
we did have a public comment from Matthew Joseph who
has that he would like to discuss the budget. And we just wanna remind you
that this is for the proposed tax rate only, that the budget public hearing will
be on August 18th. So if Matthew Joseph wanted
to clarify that, and I don't see him here, so we will add it to
the record. Joanna Brown.
Hi, Joanna Brown. I'm sorry that I'm dressed this way. I would
never approach in any other circumstance, but I heard a comment
that was made and I had to stop in before I go to my volleyball
game. The comment that was made was made
that somebody said that they support the tax increase,
but maybe to less than 220%. And then the comment
was made, maybe it's something that most probably— most people probably still won't be happy
with. Um, and that got me off of
watching it on my phone and here in front of you, because that's not the
way government works. Government's for the people. So the majority of
the people voted you guys into where you are. The majority of the people are
represented by you, so the majority of the people should be happy with the decisions
that are made. So I guess I just wanted to reiterate
that that's— a democracy is a government for
the people, by the people, and we are in a democratic republic where we
vote for representatives who represent the majority. So that comment
of maybe the majority will be upset, but that's fine, do what you want to
do— no, remember that the majority of the people are why
we have this government and why you're all sitting where you are, because the majority
of us voted for you. Um, and I guess my other really
quick comment before I head out the door was just thanking Ms.
Rasmussen for clarifying that again it's been put out,
which I felt like it was a little bit confusing, that under
that truth in taxation, that yes, the amount per household stays the
same, but because there's more households There
is more money. So, um,
I hope that most people don't come from a house where dinner was
mom coming home with a can of beans and saying that's all she could afford,
and that that can of beans now cost her $37 instead
of $2 because now she was getting an overdraft fee for it.
But I hope that the city isn't going in a direction
because we need whatever these capital projects
are, to put its citizens in that kind of a position.
'Cause I'm grateful I'm not in that position anymore, but I have been, and it
sounds like a lot of our citizens also know
what that feels like. So I'll just ask you to remember
that you represent the majority. Remember,
like, try to make the majority happy, I guess. Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
These public comments are from participants who showed up today,
but does not— they do not wanna make a verbal comment. So I'll just read
the names. They're all in opposition to the tax increase, to be clear.
Trenton Webb, Derek Rappel-Eye,
M. Patrick Mayo, Brianna Nelson,
Alex Nelson, Jessica Diemers,
David Gordette, and Vienna Portela.
Portela.
Thank you.
These are the public comments that came in through via email,
and I am unsure if they are in attendance, so I'll call your name,
and if you're here, come on up. Brittany Mitchell.
She's in opposition to the tax increase, so we'll get that in
the record. Lily Anna Elliott,
also in opposition. Cammie Watterson,
also not here. She states, I'm all
for keeping the city running safe, but why is it 220%?
So she doesn't say for or against. Jill Jones.
I do not see her here. She wishes to pause
the increase of the property taxes. Susanna Norris.
She's writing to voice the strong opposition to the 220%
increase. Carly King.
Also not here. Opposition to the increase as well.
Brenda Martinez. Hold on. Oh, we do have Carly
King online. Let me double-check that.
Thank you, Carson. Okay, we do have Carly King online,
so we will come back to her. Brenda Martinez.
I do see a Brenda online, so that could be her. Um,
and she— her statement is, uh, the point is lack
of transparency Transparency, so we will get that added in.
Zachary Vance—he
doesn't say for or against either. And then Martin
Indreboi—I
do not see that, and he does not also say for or against.
Okay, so now we're going to move to the virtual comment.
Period. And as a reminder, I will
unmute your mic if you are online, and it will tell you to
unmute it on your side. I will start the timer once you start
speaking, and then once you are finished, you're welcome to stay online to
watch the meeting, but not required to, as you'll only be able to speak
once. Am I missing anything else? Okay, we're just gonna go ahead and start
at the beginning. I see AJ online. I do not see last names on some
of them, so please state your first and last name when you jump on as
well. Okay, we're going to move over to that.
AJ, you should be able to unmute your mic.
Hi, everyone.
He's— looks like he's still muted, so we might have
to come back to him. Should I
unmute? No?
Okay, we're gonna go past AJ and we're gonna go over to Alex Washburn.
See if I can get this one to work. Here we go.
Good evening, Mayor, council members,
and fellow residents. My name is Alex Washburn. Over the
past week, I've spent dozens of hours reading the city's budgets, attending meetings,
filing grandma requests, and trying to understand why Eagle Mountain is proposing
what amounts to a 220% property tax increase.
Yesterday, I had the opportunity to spend about an hour meeting with Mayor
Jared Gray, the city manager, Council Member Clark, and members of the
finance team. I sincerely appreciate each of them taking the time to answer
my questions because that meeting genuinely changed my understanding
of several things. I now have a much better understanding of
how Utah's truth-in-tax law has affected
Eagle Mountain over the last 15 years. As property taxes— values increased,
the certified property tax rate decreased, while the
cost of providing services, especially especially law enforcement, continued to rise.
I now understand why the city has gradually had to use more
and more of the general fund to cover the increasing cost of
the sheriff's contract, leaving less capacity for roads,
infrastructure, parks, and other priorities. I believe that's
a real problem, and I believe it needs to be addressed. However, I still have
2 significant concerns. The first is the policy objective
itself. During yesterday's meeting, it was explained that this recommendation
was built around fully funding the sheriff's contract through property taxes.
But when I reviewed the 2010 budget, the last time there's a tax increase,
I found that property tax revenue was approximately $974,000
while police expenditures were approximately $2 million. So unless I'm
misunderstanding those numbers, property taxes did not fully fund law enforcement
even then. That tells me that fully funding the sheriff's
contract through property taxes isn't simply restoring the way things have always in,
it's a policy decision. And I think taxpayers deserve to understand
why that policy was chosen. Why is it better to have property
taxes fully fund the sheriff's contract instead of continuing to fund
it through a combination of property taxes and other general fund revenues
as the city has historically done? My second concern is how
the amount of this increase was determined. During yesterday's
meeting, I asked what I thought was a simple question. If this proposed
tax increase were reduced didn't pass at all, what projects
or priorities would actually be delayed or eliminated. The answer was
that those decisions haven't been made yet. I appreciate the
city genuinely wants public input before making those decisions,
but I respectfully believe that the analysis should have come first.
30 seconds remaining. I wish the city had come
to the public with several funding scenarios. If we approve the full increase, if we
reduce it by 10%, or reduce by 20%. What projects
would have to wait? That would allow taxpayers to have an informed discussion about
priorities instead of simply reacting. Based on everything,
I support raising it to $1.5 million to fund the 2027
sheriff's contract, but I oppose the increase beyond that unless
the city can clearly explain exactly what the remaining dollars will fund
and what projects or priorities— You can't talk—
The next one we have in line is Amy Larcher.
I'm going to go ahead and allow you to talk and unmute your mic.
It looks like she left. Ashley Garside?
Lacey, I see Ashley's on there twice. Is there a chance that
the other mic that she could be using— maybe unmute both of them? Yeah,
let me try to— You unmuted me on accident.
Do I need to click
it again? We will move on to Ben Crabtree.
One moment. Okay, thank you.
All right, Ben.
Thanks. Sorry, I'm just driving back. I really
appreciate, uh, each member of the City Council and, uh, Mayor for hearing our comments.
And I think most of, most of what I would have said is
already— has already been stated, um,
in, in regards to those who are on fixed incomes who Uh,
don't have room in the budget for this level of increase.
Uh, it's just, it's way too much. Um, and I also
appreciate— I don't remember her name, but the,
uh, she mentioned that there have been communications
that have been sent out from the city, uh, about some of these, uh,
some, some of the projects that need to be done or are going to be,
um, done. I would love to see those as well. I think a lot of
us are feeling that same, feeling that same way.
I would also follow up with, follow up on some
of the other comments that were made about the data centers. I really,
I can't imagine how companies
like Meta and Google can come out here and
I know they're gonna, they're gonna, they can, they have
enough money to fund wherever they want to build. And so why would we I
don't know the nature of the negotiations, but I also run my
own business. And so I also have 6 kids. I'm trying to support 6 kids.
And so hearing this, hearing this increase is just, is just wild.
And why are we passing it on to the taxpayers when
we could get some of these companies who are building infrastructure that's going
to increase our cost of electricity and increase the cost of water
to, to foot some of these bills? It just seems like that would be a
better approach. And again,
just think of, think of the number of people in our community.
I would— I hope to be more involved in future city council meetings
and look up some of the data behind our community and
looking at how many people are really struggling.
And from a financial standpoint, and what people are doing to try
and already make ends meet, what can we do? Thank you.
in other ways besides raising taxes like this, especially at such a high rate,
to help lower their burdens. That's what I have to
say. Thank you. Okay, we're going
to try Amy Larcher again. Just give us
Looks like she left again. Let's go down to Brenda.
I don't know your last name, Brenda.
Okay, we'll move on
to Brett.
Hi.
Okay, we'll move on to Bruce.
Bruce, can you hear us?
I think so.
Cam Pugh.
Can you hear me okay? Yep, go ahead.
Awesome. Yeah, I'm just gonna say simply I agree with everybody. Um,
I think you represent the people who voted you in.
I think that the majority has a consensus
that transparency, um,
hasn't been met for an ask this big.
I think a lot of families open
their wallet and they don't see much.
And I think that you as a council need
to look in your wallets and simply ask yourself,
who do you represent?
You know, I came from a big family,
and I saw
my parents struggle to put food on the table.
And, you know, it hurts,
I think, every person who grew up seeing
their parents Struggle to put
just a meal on the table to feed their kids.
And, um, for a city as big as Eagle Mountain,
I'll be honest with you,
it's not just not right, it's deceptive,
and it's kind of evil to think that you
as a council are going to ask each citizen to open their
pockets, their wallets that might be empty and
say, you know what, we haven't been transparent with you, but we're
going to ask a huge, huge favor. Give me money that
you don't have.
That's all I have to say.
Thanks, Cam. We're going to move on to Carly King.
All right,
I think I'm unmuted. Um, yep, we can hear you. My name,
my name is Carly King. I have lived in Eagle Mountain
for about 11 years, and initially I wasn't going to share very much about
myself. I don't like speaking, but hearing that the
Council members have pretty
much already made up their minds, saying that their hands were
being forced. I feel like it's important for you guys to all understand
the weight that you are putting on the shoulders of your citizens.
Um, so just a little bit about my family. I'm the mom of
a 2-year-old. My husband and I both work full-time. I have
to manage working full-time while also being home with my daughter. Thank you.
And trying to be a present parent to her while keeping my job.
This is my reality because I can't— we can't afford to lose one
of our incomes. We already struggle as it is.
We have medical debt, bills, groceries, gas, diapers,
as does everyone else. And sometimes we have to choose
between any one of those items. Which one are we going to pay this month?
Thank you. Um, so I
am against this 220% tax increase. This is going to
devastate many families in Eagle Mountains.
Single-family incomes will become nonexistent,
and this is going to force many mothers that are able to currently
stay home with their kids back into the workforce.
Moms deserve better. And so do those kids.
Um, voting for this is a vote— um,
sorry, the city is going to, um, make a decision
without being transparent, and the suggestion
of a 220% increase is pretty egregious.
We haven't been presented with data. We've just been told it's going to public
safety. Thank you. And like many other people have echoed, nobody's against
public safety, but you aren't being truthful.
Everyone's already living paycheck to paycheck.
So what you're asking is for people to take time away from their families,
to work more hours, and to cut back on necessities,
um, just to be able to afford this tax increase.
You should all be ashamed. Thank you. Whoever votes for this,
you are the ones that have to go home and live with yourself. 30 seconds
remaining. You're stealing from the pockets of the citizens of the city.
Eagle Mountain needs to manage our tax dollars better.
You need to hold the city employees to a higher standard, hold them
accountable for fraud, waste, and abuse. In addition,
stop giving data centers astronomical
tax breaks. Thank you.
Thank you. Uh, next one we have is Chris. I don't have
a last name on this. We will ask to unmute.
Okay, moving on. Um, the next one we have is just Citizen.
I'm unsure if you would like to make a public comment.
Okay, the next one we have is Courtney.
All right, uh, the next one we have, the title is Elder and Sister Squire.
Unmute your mic if you'd like to give a public comment at this time.
Okay, the next one we have is Embritt.
Um,
we have, we have a couple more, so why don't we do this? Um,
if you would like to give a public comment and you're currently on our Zoom
portal, will you please raise your hand?
All right, that'll work.
All right, oops, there we go. We're going to start with Steve Muggleson.
Can you hear me? Yes, there you go. Yep. Okay, uh, like everyone
here, I want my community to be safe. I support our deputies, and I support
giving law enforcement the resources that they need to to protect the citizens.
This isn't about public safety. This isn't whether
or not public safety is important, because it is. But placing this tax burden
solely on the residents is egregious. Eagle Mountain residents
are already carrying heavier financial burdens than they were just
a few years ago. A Forbes survey finds that 78% of
Americans consider themselves living paycheck to paycheck. Mortgage payments
have increased. Property insurance has gone up. Groceries cost more.
Utilities cost more. Nearly every household expense
has risen. People must make difficult choices every month,
and now the city is asking them to shoulder one of the largest property tax
increases in its history. At the same time, Eagle Mountain
has welcomed some of the largest and wealthiest companies in the world to
build multi-million dollar data centers in our community.
To attract these projects, the city approved redevelopment agreements
that reimburse a substantial portion of the new property
tax revenue those developments generate.
Homeowners should not become the default solution every time
the city needs more revenue, while generous incentive agreements
remain in place for billion-dollar companies. How much tax
revenue has been reimbursed to these major data center develop— This
money is going straight to the pockets of those who don't even know Eagle Mountain
exists and do not support the community that they use. This isn't
about opposing growth or law enforcement. This is about fairness,
accountability, and transparency. Thank you.
Thanks, Steve. We'll move on to Joel Anderson online.
Yeah, thanks for taking your time to listen
to us. A lot of what I was going to say has already been said,
so let me just maybe pitch one possible
alternative to the 220% increase.
Doing a little bit of research,
looking back at 2016,
we were paying about $6.50 $67.53
per capita for public safety. In 2026, it's estimated
to be about $63.16 per capita,
adjusted for— adjusted to 2016
dollars. So we're spending roughly
6.9%, uh, less than,
than what we should be if we were to be on par with 2016.
So, if we were to do something like maybe add
3 new sheriffs rather than 7, that would
get us actually a little bit over that, being on par with 2016.
And then if we were to take that $5.3 million that
is currently being pulled from other
budgets to help help pay for the current
sheriff contract. If we were to cut that in half and
leave half of it to pay for sheriffs
and public safety, and then put the other roughly $2.7
million back toward the original,
I guess, back toward other projects,
that would— That would be a good idea. leave the new property tax—
let's see, excuse me. Anyway, that would result
in about an 8% property tax increase that would be required
to get us into that range.
Anyway, maybe something like that might be an alternative that it
would reduce the the tax
change from 220% to 8%, it would put
$2.7 million back into other projects, and it would increase
the sheriff's capacity by 3 sheriffs.
And so anyway, just, just a thought, something along
those lines possibly could be a more tempered approach to
what's needed here. 30 seconds remaining.
Let's see, I did. Yeah, also, well, yeah, that's all
I have to say. I think everything else has been said. I don't want to
beat a dead horse. Thank you.
Thanks, Joel. Uh, the next one we have is Joe. I do not have a
last name on here, so please ensure that you give us your last name for
the record. Yes, my name is Joe Richmond.
Um, thank you for the time. Um,
so it's interesting going towards the end of this comment.
Thank you. In the last year and a half, there have been a lot of
common themes that have come up: lack of transparency,
not knowing where the money's going, and we're asking to pay more money,
more in taxes to cover things. And maybe,
you know, the City Council— being in leadership is not easy. I understand that.
I've been in leadership my entire career, and I understand that you see
things and have context that the citizens
probably don't have, and, and that's why you're elected.
But part of your job as being elected is to communicate
well, to be transparent, to simplify and make
it easy for citizens who— how many people have come up who have
sacrificed to be here to, to voice their
comment and their opposition to this, as I am? And we don't
have time in our daily lives to, to research this and become
experts. And so if this many people are coming to the
table and are opposed to this because we don't understand it and
it's not clear where the money's going, then you have failed at
your job at leadership. It is your job to help
us understand it. It's your job to— we may not like it,
but if we can understand it, I think we have a better chance of supporting
something. We have to do that all the time as adults. as leaders,
right? So that is what I ask and expect from
leadership. And I think everybody that's present in
the room, that's online, that's listening, and those that haven't
been able to join to voice their opinion— I've talked to so many people who
can't even join because they're busy running businesses, they're busy with life,
and they can't vote their— voice their opinion here. So my—
I want to voice my opposition to this. Not because it's a
big increase. Maybe it's needed, but you have not done your job
to let us— to simplify, to help us to understand what's
happening. I mean, and especially with the data centers,
help us to understand how there is such a— how
we're giving such tax breaks to these, these large
corporations with deep pockets, and yet families And
households that don't have deep pockets, we can't just raise funds
for 220% for— to buy a
new car or whatever. 30 seconds remaining. So I'm asking that,
please take a step back, pause, and do a
better job of communicating and helping us understand what it is you're trying to
accomplish. Trust your citizens to understand what
you're seeing. and explain it to us in a simple way so that we can
maybe get behind. Maybe we don't need the 220%, maybe we
need 150% or whatever it is, but help us understand it.
Thank you for your time.
The last one we have online is Zachary Vance.
Hello. I feel like Joe led right into my points.
Basically, as a Democracy as
an experiment in self-governance. A lot of this comes down to adequate
representation. And I don't even know where the citizenry lands on how many support it,
how many reject it. I get the feeling after tonight that if you took this
to some kind of ballot initiative somehow, we would likely be rejecting
this. And honestly, the bottom line is nobody cares what you
think as the city council. As the city council, you were elected to represent
us. So I just want to have more transparency On how you're adequately
representing the will of the people. That's what you were elected to do.
You need to represent the will of the people. And if the people are against
you and you see a better reason, like Joe just said, explain yourself.
With clear communication, we could be on board. We might support you.
But I don't even know if you're listening. I don't know if you've done anything
to listen to your constituents and adequately represent them.
That's the point of this democracy. That's the point of your job. You need
to represent your people. It does not matter what you think.
It is about the people you represent, and that is my only point.
All right, thank you, Zachary. Um, I want to reiterate,
anybody online who would like to participate, will you please raise your hand at
Okay, we're going to go ahead and move over to the email submission. Oh,
we have Joe already spoke,
correct? Joe? Yeah.
Yes, Joe Richmond already spoke.
So we will move over to the email portion. We got a couple emails through,
um, our— to the recorder. We have one from David Salazar. Thank you,
Mayor, council members, for working so hard to ensure the city can continue providing
strong public safety services and and funding the critical projects for our community needs.
My father taught me that true character is revealed when we are faced with adversity.
I appreciate each of you being willing to stand in the face of criticism and
confrontation and still make the decisions you believe are right, not for yourselves, but for
political gain, but for the long-term betterment of our city. So he
says, thank you for your service, courage, and your commitment to the future of Eagle
Mountain City. The other public comment that we got through email
is from Gary Fuchs. He did email it to the council on August 3rd.
It's a lengthy email, so we'll make sure it's part of the record. But he
says he's unable to attend. He doesn't want to pay higher taxes,
but understands the 22% increase gets people's attention and
continues to say, my hope is that the investment is followed by regular
incremental planning so Eagle Mountain never again faces the need for an increase
of this magnitude. And then the last email
we got was from Steve. received profit. It was also sent to the council,
looks like on August 6th, this morning. Thank you for
your dedication to the future of the city. I understand that proposing a tax increase
is a difficult decision. And he talks about how
the proposal will directly affect his family. He asks that you vote no to
the proposed increase and revise the budget with outcomes-based plan that lessens
the financial impact on the residents.
Mayor, that is all of the public comments that I have received at this time.
I will move it to Lacey, I will.
I'm going to forward you one that just came in at 8:03 to the council.
Can you send it to recorder at Eagle Mountain, please? Stephanie will get that
printed. Okay,
while he's doing that, can you hear me okay? Yes, we can hear you,
Mayor. I just wanted to— Mayor, Mayor, hold on.
It's the Portella, yeah. It says
on there to read it.
Yeah, remind me of her name, please. Vienna. That's right. Coretta.
No, that's not appropriate.
All right, we received it. Uh, it was, it was a packet of
opposition to the tax increase, and it's read, no other city in Utah Utah has
ever passed a 22% tax increase. 220% tax
increase. We'll get that one
printed.
Okay. So this is the email that was just received to our office from
Ethan Neal. who is a husband, father of 2, and a resident of Eagle Mountain.
If the city council chooses to approve the proposal, which would increase my property taxes
by approximately 220% and place an even greater
burden on my families already struggling in my community, I will make it
my mission to ensure residents are aware of how each council member voted. I urge
you to consider the financial impact of this proposal that will have on the families
you were elected to represent. So we'll make sure to get that printed for the
packet as well. Thank you.
Now I think we have them all, Mayor.
Okay, I just wanted to give, uh, one last chance. Is there anyone in
person that did not get a chance to speak, would like to, please make it
Anybody? I see nobody. Thank you.
Hold on, hold on, Mayor. We have one raised hand.
Hold, please. Okay, please state your name for the record and
fill out a sheet if you would. You can return it to the recorder afterwards.
Of course, will do. So my name is Chris Waldron,
and, uh, I didn't want to talk, but I kept
thinking all night, what would Rich Wood do? And he would
make his voice known. So I want I want
to applaud you for your example of fearless being able
to speak and say what you want. I listened to the Pitch Book podcast,
and I was appalled at a comment that was made about we're doing
this tax increase because the state is
going to could potentially cap the city's ability to increase
it, and to me. The fact that that's admitted
kind of shocked me. It made me think of Tiffany Walden and the
comments she's made about malfeasance. I just
don't think that's ethical to increase
at such a high rate because the state
might stop our ability to do it. It completely exemplifies
why the state would have to have that bill even
on the table. So that was it.
Thanks.
Okay, one more time, is there anyone else in person that would like to make
a comment at this time? There's one in the
back I can see. Same instructions, if you'll get a paper to
Lacey when you're done, state your name for the record. My name is Eric
Nelson. I as well didn't want to speak, but 220% is
above egregious. It's only the iron horse
or the Trojan horse. It's just the start. What 220%
is this year, what's it going to bring to us in the future?
There's claims for a new city hall, a rec center.
I agree that if this goes through, You guys aren't going
to be elected and you won't be using that city hall.
The financial burdens that are being put on the families for this
kind of increase— they can barely afford groceries, their bills,
just surviving, barely keeping their heads above water— and you want to provide
them with a community center that they can't afford to even use?
It's just so far out there.
I moved to Eagle Mountain a year ago. Moved to Eagle Mountain a year
ago because this is the only place I could afford.
And now these kinds of increases are happening.
It's going to very quickly make this a place that's not affordable to live.
I left Salt Lake County to live somewhere that I could afford.
This is going to turn into Salt Lake County if you approve this.
There will be even more problems. In this community with
a 220% increase. Support our law enforcement 100%,
but 220% doesn't need to support our law enforcement. A much
smaller number can support our law enforcement. That's all I got.
Okay, I'm going to stay, uh, in person. Was there anyone else that feels like
they did not get an opportunity to address the council?
I don't see anyone. Lacey, uh, have we received any last-minute
emails? We got one more. Yep. Okay. Hello, my name is
Elisa Harless, and, um, I've come to city
councils a little bit, and, um, I'm newer to Eagle Mountain.
I work in a local dental office here, and I
know that when I'm presenting treatment plans to families,
a lot of them struggle to provide proper dental care for their
children, for their families, because they can't afford it. I know
that we came and met with the City of Commerce, and I
know that you guys try and help small businesses,
but your choice of doing this is going to be detrimental
to those small companies that are trying to thrive. That moved
to Eagle Mountain for a purpose because they can't afford Salt Lake County. They can't
afford the east side. They move out here. They're families that both parents
work and they live on low incomes and
they already can't afford their medical bills and their dental bills. And,
you know, they ask to make payments on things and they're really struggling. And it's
real out there. And I don't know if you guys can even relate to
that. I don't know your personal situations.
But what's going on, I feel like, and I feel like a lot of people
feel like this too, that there's been a lot of mismanagement of money.
And I don't know if you guys know history, but it sounds like a lot
of the French Revolutionary, where King Louis was overspending and
keeping it secret and not being transparent with his people
until they realized what was going on, and look what happened to them. It's getting
to the point where you guys are responsible for our money, and using
it wisely. It's not your money to spend, it's our money,
and you need to treat it and respect it and have integrity
and have a voice and know how to say no and stand up
to these big corporate companies. But to me, and I feel like a lot of
people feel like that too, is there's been really a lot of poor decisions made
in the past government of the city, and we know,
we know it. Thank you. We know it and we recognize it and we've
had enough of it and we're saying no. So think about history.
Think how, you know, government has changed because of poor decisions with spending money
and being bankrupt and not telling the people, and it's gonna come out.
So for me, I feel like that's why you have to increase taxes
so much is because you're— we could be bankrupt. We don't even know.
And you have to keep increasing taxes to make up
for poor excuses and poor decisions that you guys made in the past.
And I know that some of you are new to that. 30 seconds remaining.
But there's people that have been on the board for a long time that were
part of those poor decisions, and it's unfortunate that they
still get voted in. I don't know why, um, but something has to
So, okay, thank you, uh, Lacey. I did see a couple online.
I know there's a Joe and also I just lost the other
one. Can we go to those 2 real quick? Yep. Uh, Tim Blair.
Yes, uh, I, uh, am calling
remotely now, but I just, uh, uh, couldn't let this
pass without getting my 2 cents in.
I've lived in Eagle Mountain now about 4 years. Last year
my taxes went up about $800 a year.
That's about $70 a month,
uh, for evaluation and one thing and another.
And, uh, you know, that doesn't sound like a lot, but it is to me
a lot. Uh, and, uh, I've lived all
over the United States pretty much. And,
uh, the reason the poorest places I ever lived in were the ones
that had the highest taxes. And, uh, you know,
uh, out here, this community We've got a lot of things going
for us. And I just— I
don't know that I could afford to, to keep, you know,
getting that kind of tax increase every year. So,
you know, I'm totally set against this,
this 220-something percent increase.
And just wanted to say that
I think it's a losing proposition. Thank you. So for a lot
of us. So that's all I've got. Thank you.
Okay. I think this is a different Joe.
We did hear from one Joe. So would you check and see if this— if
Joe has spoke, maybe state the last name?
Yep. He's the same one that had spoke already. Looks like he recognizes the picture.
Okay.
Was there— before I go on, I just wanted to double-check. I'm running 2
devices here. Sorry, I'm a little slow. Was there anyone else online who
did not get the opportunity to speak? If they would raise
their hand, please.
Oh, actually, I'm trying to run the 2
devices, and I believe on Joe's device, his wife wanted to speak. Roxanne, is that
correct? Uh, can we ask if Roxanne wants to speak? Gotcha.
Okay, yeah, we'll get him unmuted.
Yeah, my name is Roxanne Richmond. Go ahead,
Roxanne, we'll get you going. Okay, thank you for— thank
you for, um, listening to me. Um, my family and I have lived in Eagle
Mountain for 7 years, and we really love the community here. I really believe that
the city council members and the mayor are good people. Jared called me
personally the other day to help me understand why the city needs
more revenues, and that makes some sense.
However, I took the time to compare this proposed tax
rate of 0.00171 to
other cities in Utah County, and what I found is that that rate is extremely
high, even in comparison to cities like Orem. Thank you. Linden,
Highland, Alpine, and Saratoga Springs.
I wanted to figure out if this proposed
tax rate was sensible in comparison to other cities
which happen to have far more services,
although they're not— some of them aren't going through as much rapid development
as Eagle Mountain. But what I've concluded is
that it is an extremely high rate and that the citizens should not be asked
to foot this bill. I support improved
law enforcement, but I would ask the City Council to go back to the drawing
board and reevaluate what's
needed, prioritize and renegotiate
with the data centers and try to bring in revenues elsewhere because this
burden would be far too much and asking far too much of taxpayers.
Thank you.
Okay, if there was anyone else online, if you'd please raise your hand if
you have not spoke. One final chance there. Also, I wanted to ask
Lacey, have there been— maybe I think Stephanie's tracking— is there anyone
that has emailed in in the last few minutes that we did not get to?
We will double-check.
No, no more emails. Okay, and I don't see any hands raised
on the computer. Last call for
those in person who have not had a chance to speak. Is there anyone there
that feels like they would like to speak?
I don't see anyone standing.
Last call for anyone online, emails,
I want to make sure everybody feels like they've been heard and had a chance.
Are we good, Lacey? Uh, we have Tyler Duclos online
that just raised his hand. Okay. We'll get him unmuted.
Hi everyone, my name is Tyler Duclos. I've lived
in Eagle Mountain for over 7 years, and I lived in Lehigh
where Eagle Mountain was a part of it. Um, my whole
family lives out here. And for a tax
increase, a property tax increase of 220%,
I'm opposed to it. I'm all for supporting our police
or our sheriff's department and public safety, but I
am like most that I've heard tonight, think that we got to
go back and find it elsewhere. Taxes are killing us already.
You know, I, I can barely afford groceries. Thank you. medical supplies.
I'm a type 1 diabetic and I'm having to go without,
you know. And talking with family,
friends, neighbors, you know, majority of my
circle are all for, uh, supporting our
Sheriff's Department, public safety. But if you look
at what the city's done— You're amazing. Look at our parks, look at our,
uh, Uh, walking paths.
Even behind my house, which is a new build for the most part,
it's all gone to crap. It looks unpresentable,
ugly on the eye, and I don't think
that a 220% increase is going to help with that because the
problem's more within of like looking
of what we need to do to improve. Uh, there's countless
times I see Eagle Mountain City trucks just parked, not doing anything,
with employees just sitting there.
And I don't think that's right. If you have employees that are overworked,
I understand, but for someone to be overworked but yet
sitting in a parking lot not doing anything, that's not being overworked,
that's being lazy, and they got to be held accountable.
But I just wanted to add my 2 cents to this, and I don't think
that this is going to help us. I think it's going to hurt us as
a community to where we grow further apart.
Thank you.
Okay, I don't see any other hands raised. I don't
see anyone in person and no emails.
Is that correct? Correct.
All right. Oh wait, we have one more, one more in
person, right? No.
Yes? No? Oh yes.
Okay.
Friends, colleagues, good to see you guys.
Um, yeah, I just I quickly will say,
it's hard to squeeze money from people who have no money, but we do
have companies of global wealth income like Facebook and Google.
So it's better to try to get some strategy plans to see
what they can do because they could easily cover whatever you guys need versus squeezing
these people out. So that's just a good strategy. We could talk about how to
get a plan to see all these new companies coming in, all all these
new companies coming in, how to structure that deal better.
Kind of like the citizens in Alaska from the gold and oil, the citizens
actually get money back. And so I do believe
in the natural growth to kind of let that natural
income come as, you know, people are moving in every week into this town.
So just strategies like that. So you guys are doing great. We'll talk. Thanks.
Can you state your name for the record, please? Yeah, for the record,
James Russell. Thank you.
Okay, I don't see anyone else still. And again,
I know we want to make sure everybody's had a chance to speak.
So is that everyone? We did receive one
email. I don't recognize the name, Lee Kim, that they want
to make known that I'm against the increase. No transparency is being had.
Okay, all of the emails. I don't see any hands raised
or anyone coming forward at this time.
Last chance. Okay, I don't see anybody.
So at 9:00 PM August 6th,
we'll close this public hearing. Um, at this time,
I'd like to read our proposed property tax impact schedule.
Uh, this is just the proposed schedule. It's, uh, what's been in front of people.
I've read it in almost every single meeting. for quite some
time now. So, uh, just for some understanding,
the proposed property tax impact schedule is Eagle Mountain City will consider an
increase to its property tax rate to generate an additional $6,742,938.
The following information is intended to provide a decision— the decision
makers and the public with an explanation of how cities op— how
how the city operations would be affected if the
proposed property tax increase is adopted.
Property tax rate with no increase is 0.000530.
Property tax revenue with no increase,
$3,055,201.
Proposed revenue with tax change, $9,798,139.
Increased revenue to Eagle Mountain City,
$6,742,938.
Eagle Mountain City's 2026
proposed property tax rate,
0.001700. Estimated increase to Eagle Mountain City's property tax revenue,
220.88%. Estimated increase to the average primary resident market
value, $488,000.
Estimated tax increase, $314.03.
Total city tax, $5— or sorry,
$456.28.
Estimated increase to average businesses market value,
$2,554,303.
Estimated tax increase, $2,987.84.
Total city tax, $4,341.62.
The affected budget, sheriff's contract. The proposed budget
is $9,798,139.
The budget with no tax change is $8,290,000,
and the budget change would be $1,507,000.
$939. If a new property tax increase is approved,
the revenue will be used to fund essential public safety operations at the level approved
by the City Council. These funds will help support core functions of the
Utah County Sheriff's Office Eagle Mountain Division, including the addition
of deputies to meet the growth of the city. That is the proposed property tax
impact schedule. Thank you for, uh,
listening to that. I appreciate everybody that's made their comments. I think, as is our
custom, I want to bring this back to the council and allow
each of you to address maybe some of the notes you've made before we
start our deliberation. I would, however, ask,
and maybe counsel with my fellow council members in the same respect
of the public that they've had only 3 minutes to speak, that at this time
you each limit your comments to maybe 3 minutes and try to address
some of the questions or any of the the ideas that you have,
and then we will have also additional time to,
uh, deliberate on, on the item
in front of us. But I just wanted to give everybody a chance to,
uh, to speak concerning the public hearing and, uh,
any council, uh, questions or concerns.
So, uh, I think I'm going to start on my right,
which is Zach. Councilmember Dewish, if you want to address public— Yes,
follow up. Do you have a timer for me?
Okay. Would you like a timer? I can do a timer. I would like a
timer, please. I've got more than 3 minutes. Okay, go ahead. But I'll
keep this part to 3 minutes. First, I wanna say I'm sorry that you're here.
I am grateful that you all showed up. For those that have come, the gentleman
that was up at 2:30 this morning and got off work at 4:30 to be
here, I'm sorry that you're here.
Quite frankly, I don't want to be here. I don't want to be in
this chair. I threw my hat in the ring for Mayor Gray's city
council seat because we have had compounded serial
missteps in our city for several years. I've lived here over 20 years,
and quite frankly, we, we need to step it
up as leaders in the city. I'm hearing 4 themes.
One is affordability, which maybe I'll, I'll address
a little bit later. Transparency— we failed you.
We absolutely failed you. I took it into my own hands to, to do
a podcast. It's hard to communicate effectively to a city of 80,000 people.
The citizens page, I just didn't feel like was a good way to communicate
in, in sound bites. There's been a lot of miscommunication.
It's been told that this was passed unanimously. It was
not passed unanimously. It was. Even though that's out on the citizens
page, so I tried to put a podcast out at my own expense to try
to build context. I've put my phone number out there. I've I've
had five or six residents reach out to me personally. I've had ten to fifteen
emails, and I'm just grateful that we are here tonight.
Even though none of us wanted to be here, I'm grateful that we are here.
This process allows everyone to share their thoughts, their feelings, and it's
scary to come up. To the pulpit in front of the dais. I've stood there
myself. The second thing is the policy, which we're going to
come back to. I want to spend more time there. And then third,
the data centers. That has been one of those compounding things.
The state has floated, or policymakers at the state have
floated, the idea of socializing the MET
tax that we've all talked about, that we've all been counting on and told
that we're going to have this tax. There is a policy that was
not passed, was defeated, that would essentially take
the municipal energy tax and socialize it to other cities. In my
mind, that's wrong. We've been waiting. We've been, you know, promised that that tax
would come back to our city. So there are very active, real threats
around revenue to our city, and we're trying to manage that as
best we can along with the, with the caps.
I don't know that this is the right rate. Um, I didn't vote
for this in the first round, and I'm, I'm hoping to have a lively discussion
with everyone tonight. Thank you for being here.
Councilmember Wood. Go ahead, start my timer.
Thank you for speaking. I think everybody here that knows me or
that has listened to me knows that We're not afraid to hear your words.
We want to hear everything that you feel. And sometimes
we get stuff wrong. I mean, that's just the reality. I would tell you the
number one highlighted thing— I share your frustration. I think we did a horrible job
of communication. I, I think that's been highlighted by
every person here. And so for that, I want to apologize.
And I don't remember who the gentleman was that said it was our responsibility to
communicate that. I think it was one of the people online. I will
own that. I should have communicated.
To Zach's point, it is difficult to find a method that
we can reach to people and get truthful information out.
There is so much disinformation that is out there. It's in the media,
the social media outlet. Go to the Eagle Mountain Citizens
page. There's not— there's very little truth in anything that's being said in there.
And I debated, how do I get the information to
people? How do I tell them why I'm interested in voting for
a tax increase of any size? We're gonna have
a chance to talk about that, and I wanna address that at that point.
But I agree that there are the 4 things that we need to talk about.
What is real with data center money? What are the challenges that we're facing
from the state in their efforts
to try to raise additional revenue? Additional funds at our expense? What are some of
the laws that have been floated that were defeated that we know are coming back?
And then I think I definitely want to talk about the way that we
communicate with you. I've been very frustrated with that long before I was ever on
this council, and I don't think it's improved all that much, frankly.
I think that the information that you expected,
I would expect if I was in your seat, and we didn't provide that information
to you. And I will address that in that latter part. Thank you
for taking the time. It's a great sacrifice for you to be here.
That's not lost on me. I appreciate you being here so we can actually have
a dialogue and explain to you some of the things that we're thinking about and
where I'm gonna land is not predetermined. I will
tell you, I'm not sure where I'm gonna be at the end of this.
We did have to make a decision to be able to have this discussion.
So we started with what are our actual needs, and I'd like
an opportunity to be able to explain that to you.
Thank you. Councilmember Whiting. Thank you so
much for being here. We really, really appreciate you. We appreciate all the comments.
We appreciate you that you've stayed here already for over 3 hours,
and we hope you can stay for the duration
of the commentary here. There's been a lot of questions asked. There's a lot of
information that's going to come back your direction.
Skepticism of government is a highly healthy thing,
and I encourage it. I applaud it, and I hope the Eagle Mountain
City— the citizens here will ever remain skeptical
of government, whether it's local or state or federal. We need to
do that. We've had so much experience in the past where
there has been fraud and abuse at the levels of government. We've experienced
that even recently in the last couple weeks. For those paying attention to
hearings in Washington, D.C., we have learned that the
federal government was deceitful on numerous levels and
numerous occasions with how it handled the COVID situation.
We are learning that Dr. Fauci in his private diary was saying
one thing and publicly saying something completely different. That affected
public policy in a significant way. The social distancing was a
lie. There is no science behind it. Dr. Fauci admits that.
That's what shut down our businesses. That's what shut down our schools. That's what shut
down our churches. And that is what led to massive inflation.
That's what led to significant costs we are now experiencing.
But I only bring that up because skepticism
is healthy. You need to come before us and say, you guys need to document
this, that, and the other. You have the right to know.
You need to make sure that we're not doing the same thing that other government
leaders have done. So I applaud that you're here. The only thing that's sad
about it is we only have a few of you here. There are so many
online that will get their information from social media
where there are only half-truths, or people think they have the truth and lead a
whole garrison of people the wrong direction. So I hope you'll stay so we
can have a dialogue that can that can be healthy, where we can transmit information
as to why would we consider an increase? Why would we do something that would
be unpopular? Why would we want to do that?
It would be easy for any of us to be the single
champion and have a whole— people rally behind us.
Why would we consider the tax increase? So I hope you'll stay so we can
have additional discussion, and I really appreciate again that you're here. Thank you.
Okay, thank you. Councilmember Wright, go ahead. Thank you,
Mayor. It's been good to hear from you.
Um, somebody said that we're going to take the easy way out. I can assure
you this is not the easy way out. Um,
the easy way out is really ignoring the needs that the city is experiencing,
the growth that we're, that we're, that we're dealing with. The loss
of employees because we can't keep
them even in a median area as far as payroll goes.
There's a lot that we need to discuss, but I do want to thank you
for coming. I appreciate you sharing your thoughts. I really
hope you'll listen to the discussion that's going to ensue because I
don't get the feeling, I haven't had the feeling that that this is settled in
an exact place, but we're going to have some dialogue
and some discussion about it. But I am absolutely
considering a tax increase for all of the right reasons.
And some of you are going to shake your heads and say, well,
what are the right reasons? We're going to have that discussion.
It's not the easy way out. In fact, it's the most difficult path that we
have to take forward. The easy way is to say we're not going to do
anything, and what we're going to do is just continue to reduce services, and we're
not going to take care of those things that we, that we own and that
we should be taking care of. And that's what we've done for a number
of years. It's always tighten your belt, figure out a
way forward without dealing with the hard problems
of the fact that we don't have the resources that we need to take
care of those things that we have.
It really is a resourcing problem. And I can assure you
this, this city council and those of the very short past
have been anxiously engaged in creating economic development that
is going to bear fruit. I'm confident of that.
And you shake your heads no, and you can disbelieve that, but the day
will come when Eagle Mountain will be known as one of the most I
want to use the right word— prosperous cities in
Utah County, certainly, and within the state of Utah. Those days
are on our horizon, but they are not today. They are coming.
And I know Mayor Gray's gotten in trouble for saying that, and I'm going to
do you a favor. I'm started— I've
started into my second term. This is my 5th year. I'm not going to rerun.
I am here to do— 30 seconds remaining. And to make the right decisions and
to make the changes. And we have said no. We have said no on multiple
occasions, in multiple ways, and made very hard decisions.
We've adjusted the way development happens in Eagle Mountain, the way the water is allocated.
We have made some tremendous strides in holding the development
community accountable when they were not being held accountable prior to my arrival
here. I'm sure we'll talk a little bit more about that.
My time's about out, but thank you for being here.
Okay, yeah, go ahead, uh, Councilor McClark.
Thank you all for being here tonight. Um, I totally
get why people are angry, and it makes sense that you're mistrustful,
and it even makes sense why maybe you're a little bit afraid that your quality
of life and your ability to take care of your family and provide for
for their needs could change. And the fact is, is I feel all
of those same things. Before I ran
for city council, I was pissed that the city was spending money
on a park that I didn't think we had money for.
And I would rant and rave on Facebook, and I would tag all my elected
officials and ask them to be accountable for all of that.
And As I got
into office, I started to realize that there's way more
than I ever could have comprehended.
And frankly, serving the city's an
honor, but it's also super hard because
there were a lot of decisions made in the early years of the city that
set us up for for a trajectory that makes it so
that we don't have as much control now.
I want you to know too that this isn't settled. I spent
a lot of time going through budgets. I spent a lot of time going through
what our city's
doing, what other cities are doing, and trying to find ways that we could
save money so that we don't have to raise taxes.
But like my colleagues up here have said, it would be easy
for us just to say no and not look at the real needs that we
have as a city. I think the biggest thing that we have to figure
out tonight while we're meeting with you guys is what
do we cut? What are the priorities that matter the
most to the people of our community? Because there's
more needs than we have money. Thank you. We do need to do a better
job of communicating. Mayor Gray and this council
have tried to come to your neighborhoods and do a listening
tour. We've tried to go to farmers markets, but it's still not enough.
It's still not enough, and we
need to do better.
I want to thank you all for being here. I hope that we get an
opportunity to talk about some of the
history, some of the changes, some of the reasons for the things that we do.
30 seconds remaining. Um, and I hope that you
guys get a chance to stay and be a part of that conversation. So thank
you. Okay,
now something a little different. Uh, council kind of knew that they were going
to get a chance, and as they always do, uh, but this part maybe they
didn't know. I'm just going to ask, you can say no, Our City Manager
Ben Reeves has been a great addition to our city and has
a wealth of knowledge. I'm just going to ask if there are any comments that
you'd like to make and if there's any maybe clarifying things
or anything that you can help the public or the council. And you can say
no. And following that, I do know that Sheriff Smith is also in the audience
and give him a chance to represent the Sheriff's Department if he
wishes. Uh, I don't mean to put you on the spot, but I just wanted
to, to lay that out there.
Thank you, Mayor. And, and I echo the comments of the council,
and I echo the, the fact that it is a great honor to
serve this community. Um, I've been here just a short time,
and, um, but I've seen, uh, Eagle Mountain City from afar for—
since its inception back in 1996 when 250 residents
came together to, to collectively work to build towards a brighter
future. And today here we are inheriting, um,
80— a city of 80,000, and, and yet the services and
the, the work and the infrastructure and everything that is needed is so essential
in order to enhance and protect and preserve the quality
of life that you've enjoyed for these last 30 years. Coming in new,
I, I just look and applaud
at our, our first responders, both with the Sheriff's Department and with, with UFA
and our city staff and all that they do. And I— it's what's hard for
me is that I truly feel like for many, many years that they've been
working with basically an arm tied behind their back.
We haven't invested in them. And, and I think there is a, a strong
desire for, you know, the, the mentality of use it up, wear it out,
make it do what it do without. And that's great. But there's also a
certain expectation that our property values go down if we don't
take care of our open spaces, if we don't take care of our parks.
People go to other areas. I know it was talked a lot
about the data centers. I wasn't here when the first data center was approved,
but I can tell you that the incentives given to the first
data center brought the next, and then that brought the next. And with each subsequent
data center to today, there's been less incentive, less incentive to that. There's no incentives
today, and, and they're going the other direction
and bringing money to the table up front. And so if it wasn't for
some of the decisions of the past, we wouldn't have inherited the bright
future as well. And so it's hard to stand in judgment for those who have
been here before, but I can tell you today that our city staff is
about the third of the size of city staff
of equivalent population, and they are working their hearts out,
and they care, and they, they, they love the city that they work
for, they love the council that they work for, and they love serving the people
that they work for. And yet it's hard to hear after day after day that,
you know, we suck, we're not keeping up, we're not keeping the
parks up, we're not keeping the trails up. Well, we can only do what we
can do with the staff that we have, and we can only provide that level
of service that we can afford to accomplish. 30 seconds
remaining. And so ultimately, this is a policy decision,
and I will support the council in whatever they do, and I am absolutely confident
our staff will support the council in whatever they decide, and they will do the
very best with whatever resources that you entrust to them. But at the same time,
please recognize that we're in it together. We are one team. We're one family.
We're one Eagle Mountain City. We all live here. We all want to see our
kids and grandkids live here in the future as well. Thank you.
I can't see Sheriff Smith off the screen, but is he—
there he is. Yep. Thank you, Mayor.
Super excited to speak at something like this.
So, so hey, I, you know, honestly, I get PTSD
with these type of meetings. I hate them. I feel for
everybody that spoke tonight. My heart goes out to you.
It's a horrible thing. I feel for the council. It's a tough decision.
It's easy to armchair quarterback this and
criticize, but I can tell you, as somebody who sits in the seat
also, it's It's a whole different story when you're sitting in the seat and you
have to make the decision. So I respect that.
I respect you for what you're doing. And what I will say
as the sheriff is we are extremely proud
to be your law enforcement out
in Eagle Mountain. We are Eagle Mountain out here.
The deputies that we send out here are The finest deputies
that we have in the sheriff's office. You are getting high-quality
people. We're able to, through the sheriff's office, we're able to recruit
top officers. A lot of times, you know, I get chiefs that are mad at
me. We're taking them from other cities because they want to come work for
the sheriff's office. And so Eagle Mountain benefits from that.
And what I will tell you is it's
a tough decision to come to Eagle Mountain Council and say, hey, we need
this. But as we look at crime, as we look at the growth of this
city, I'll tell you, as far as the truth in taxation
and what it costs to do it, again, that's a really tough decision. But that's
not what I look at. I look at how do we keep Eagle Mountain
safe? How do we keep Eagle Mountain a community that people want
to move to, that people feel comfortable living in, that people feel like
their public safety is doing their jobs. I come out and I campaign.
I go to meetings and I'll tell you what I hear,
not in a Truth in Taxation meeting, but what I hear overwhelmingly from people
is they're upset. They're upset because they called
on, you know, maybe something lower level on
the food chain of law enforcement and they didn't get the response they needed.
Why aren't you guys responding? And I can tell you the reason why is is
because the, the deputies are basically going from call to call to
call. And I heard a few comments tonight about, well, we saw them getting a
drink at 7-Eleven or wherever they were. And I've told them,
and I challenge them, I'm like, if you have downtime, I would rather have
you— 30 seconds remaining— instead of coming to the office and hanging out,
I would rather have you going somewhere like that to take a break and
talk to the community, be out there with the community. So we,
we want to be your police force. And what I will, what I will guarantee
you as your sheriff is we're not asking for anything that's not needed out here.
It is, it is definitely needed. Actually, more is needed. I've heard
a few comments about doing your own police. That's on
the table if they want, but I think the council knows in a feasibility study
that is nowhere— it's not— Your time is up. Thank you. It's not even close
to what you're getting for your Okay,
thank you. And I will add a couple comments I forgot to do
earlier. But some of the things like that were brought
up in the meeting, impact fees and grants, those are all one-time monies.
These deputies that we hire will be ongoing expenses year over year
with their salaries. Just, just as thoughts for some
of the questions that were brought up. Thank you. Also, I work extensively
with our data center partners. I've been in office now
213 days, and I've got to know those guys very,
very well. And I did— in the course of the week, I wanted
to know some of the actual numbers for the community to understand.
And QTS actually provided some talking points just to— You
guys can take these numbers back and look at what it is
that we've been telling you Coming. They're under construction. And so these,
these haven't been fully realized yet.
But the property tax impact from QTS, they're committed to building within our
city. In the new buildings, there's 3 buildings that are under construction right now.
They're looking to break ground on 2 more buildings just to the north. The impact
will generate over $19 million a year
for our local jurisdictions. And Evan obviously
knows these numbers, and we're going through these numbers every day. Yeah. Just for Eagle
Mountain City alone, in our current tax rate, that Eagle Mountain City,
that would be $2.7 million a year.
The Utah County would get $1.7 million. Here's the big one. I heard of
this a lot during this, you know, the concerns about the school district.
Lake Mountain School District on the current high building would get $10.4
million a year. That's an additional $10.4 million for the budget.
Every 3 years that builds an elementary school. So when I
mentioned earlier on that this money is coming, these are the actual numbers.
Unified Fire District under the current taxing system would get $3.2
million. We're looking by next year to bring that taxing authority back
in-house. Add that to the city amount and you would see a little
over $5 million to the city rather than the $2.7 million. So those
are the kind of numbers Utah Central Water District would get. Okay. We get
almost $1 million, and then the other districts just shy
of $500,000. Another thing is QTS was granted
some tax incentives when they started those
first 3 buildings. They came back on these next 2— we didn't even ask this—
and said, hey, by the way, you guys have been so great to us,
we don't want any incentives on these next builds. Just, we're going to be full
taxpayers starting day one. So I want that to soak in a little bit
that We are negotiating and we are working
with these people, and they are going to contribute right around
the corner. These dollars are going to be realized right away. We haven't even
talked about the MET that that also generates. So,
and another point, we were trying to figure out how to
widen Pony Express here a couple of weeks ago.
QTS, I made one phone call to them and said,
hey, maybe we could do a reimbursement agreement, like how to work this out.
That was some ideas talked about in the city hall.
I called them and said, you know what, I don't feel like this is a
burden the residents should bear. Some of that traffic on Pony Express is because of
their workers. I said, it's about a $5 million bill with 2 stoplights,
and 2 of those stoplights are areas that turn towards their development.
It's about a $5 million ask, and I asked them to consider
helping us with that, at least half or most.
Uh, the, the people that are charged
with making those decisions said, give me just a minute, hung the phone up
and called me right back and said, you know what, not only will we help,
we'll pay for that entire $5 million bill. That road will be built. So now
our internal staff, our engineers are working hard to make sure that we can get
that as soon as possible. I think we'll see some of it this year and
some in the future. So I just want you to know that these data centers
are invested in our community. Thank you. And not just at their site,
but in areas where we direct that we need some help.
So, uh, some of those numbers are now out
there, and you're welcome to get further information.
I would say those are estimated a little bit, but we've done
a lot of math over the last week just so that we can provide that
with some fairly good confidence that that's the direction that we're headed on
just that one site. Right. That does not include some of the other data
centers. So I just wanted to get that out there as we move forward in
this discussion. I think it's time— I just
want to reach out to Marcus, Lacey.
I know Kimberly's there. Procedurally, if we missed anything that
we need to address at this time before I go on to item number 4,
or the council.
Uh, looks like we are okay. Marcus, Kimberly, and I, we have
everything we need. Thank you. I think we're good. Okay, and if the
council has any questions or as we move forward, you're welcome to
let me know, but I think it's time we move on to item number 4
on our agenda, which is a resolution of Eagle Mountain City approving a property
tax increase above the certified tax rate for fiscal year '26-'27.
I think we've talked about this a lot through our budget process
and whatnot. So at this time, I'd just like to turn it over to the
council if you have any questions or comments. I know there are a few of
you that said that you want to get into a little more detail at this
point. Uh, so I'm open to,
uh, raise your hand, let me know if you'd like to speak, and we'll
try to be as orderly as possible. Again, I appreciate you guys allowing me to
do this remotely, but whoever wants to speak, uh, Let me know.
Mayor, really quick, I think you guys have asked the question about
transparency, and you're like, we want a line-by-line,
uh, explanation of the budget and what the money's being spent on.
And I want you guys to know that that document exists.
And not only does that document exist right now for this year's budget,
but it exists for all of the previous year's budgets, and they are
all on our city website. There's an interactive
budget so you can kind of see what the goals are for every
single department, what their projects are that they're working on.
So if it's parks, what parks they're upgrading.
If it's the attorney's office, what contracts
and different things they're working on. And it's important to us that
you guys know today when you go home that that exists,
and we are 100% transparent and
accountable to you guys. We want you to know that it's out there.
We've done a crappy job of helping you know where it is,
but it exists. And I think it's really
important for you guys to know that it's there.
Thanks.
Yeah, I think to your point, a lot of people have used the word transparency
instead of communication. Transparency, everything that we've done has been in an
open and public meeting, and it's very transparent.
What it isn't is easy to get it out to the public in
a form maybe easy to understand or whatnot. So the communication side,
we've done our best, and we try, and we improve every day. But transparency is
definitely— everything we've done has been in the open. So.
Next, is that Council Member Huish? You go ahead.
Yeah, I just want to go, go deeper into the transparency piece.
When the— this is my understanding, and, and Ben,
you can correct me if I misstep anywhere, okay?
I'm going to be careful. But when the application was submitted
for the policy to cover 100% of the sheriff's contract
100% with property taxes. That was the
application. And in the state of Utah, to vary from that
application would completely disrupt this entire process.
So you have the communication that was put out
to communicate the policy, but it's obvious that you
take $6.7 million minus roughly $1.5 million and
there's a gap there. It's like, well, what happens with that money,
right? And that's not part of the initial application. That's a separate
discussion. So I want to, if it's okay to talk
about— It's okay. All right. I just want to be clear. This is something
that I also struggled with in understanding and trying to communicate.
So some of the things as a council that we've talked about,
there are several projects going on within the city. There's also several
staffing shortfalls. Number one, we've talked about
getting our staff to 90%. I believe it's 90% of
the median. Is that correct, Ben? We're not there. Our staff
is underpaid. My neighbor used to work in the city of Eagle Mountain.
He now drives to Herriman. They just pay more. He makes more money there.
He is excellent with concrete work, and we
train people up. We hire them here. We train them and then we lose them
to other cities. And the cost of training is expensive. If for those of
you that are business owners, it's expensive to train people and it's painful
when you lose them because of salary.
So part of the contemplation with the freed
up funds is to increase based
on merit and getting people up to that level to where they're not
even above average, but at,
at the 90% of the median, of the
middle. Okay, so not even there. That cost is about $525,000
to do that. So there's that.
There's also the contemplation. These, these are positions
that would impact the general fund.
There's about 18 part-time
and full-time positions. 13 of those, in my estimation, have to do with our
parks. And I'm just gonna— I won't go through each specific salary,
but I would like to mention, uh, the, the different jobs.
So we, we've contemplated, uh,
hiring 3 open space, uh,
employees for— So when you're on Eagle Mountain Citizens
page and you see someone complaining about My trail needs to be cleaned. We've got
trails all over. We've got, I don't know, hundreds of miles of
trail. I have them behind my house and they get overgrown. And we've, we've got
a staff where that's what they're out doing. We've contemplated
having 3 parks technicians. The other day
I was at Quarry Ride, and I'm sorry if I'm going— is it okay?
Go. Okay. I just have a lot to say. I've been thinking
about this a lot. I was at Corey Ride at
the dunk tank actually yesterday with the Youth Council, and I was walking around the
park and I was like, the grass actually looks good. The last time
I was Corey Ride, it looked terrible. And I thought, we sold our utility for
this park and we just let it go. And I happened to run into one
of the parks techs that was there. I said, you've got—
this park looks good. I don't know what you're doing, but it does not look
like the park by my house. The park by my house is dying. There's weeds
everywhere, and you can drive around Eagle Mountain and
see those conditions. And he said, you know, we took this park back in-house,
meaning our employees are taking care of this park.
We have a lot of contract work that happens throughout
the city in our parks, and they don't look great. So we've contemplated
hiring more parks crews so that we can actually control the quality and
service level. Thank you. We've considered
recreation.
We have brought soccer back in-house. So our
ball fields, our soccer fields are not in great condition.
Some of the kids that are playing are skinning their knees.
Maybe that's okay. For me, I think we can do better there.
We've also contemplated a streets operator, sealing the cracks. Now it's
true when you build a development and you charge impact fees to a
developer, that developer is not on the hook for the maintenance
in perpetuity. There's just not a fund that exists to
maintain those streets, and there are real costs. So we've contemplated
hiring there. There's also 5 positions considered around
engineering and just day-to-day operations. We have
a lot of Well, Ben can probably speak to this, to turnover within
the city regarding HR. Our purchasing
agent is overwhelmed. Last year asked for— to
hire somebody. We did not hire that person. She's working
a lot of overtime, and, you know,
it's emotionally exhausting. So these are some of the things
that freed up funds that we're contemplating. Thank you.
This was in the May 26th meeting. I talked about
this specifically. And you can go listen to those. I know nobody
wants to go listen to 6 hours of budget meetings of city council. That's not
your job. That's our job. But these are things that weren't communicated,
I think out of a fear of crossing the line with the application
that was filled. So I just want to clarify that.
And if there's anything that I communicated in in the podcast that I put
out there was not intended to mislead anybody or to confuse
anyone. It was meant to bring more context that I didn't feel like was being
put out there in, um, in the Eagle Mountain Citizens page.
So I'll just pause there on transparency, and I have more around
policy that I'd love to discuss. Yeah, and I think the,
the key to that, Zach, what you're talking about is,
uh, more about the budget and the budget process than,
than so much this tax, but just all of the different things in our budget
that we are dealing with, right? So appreciate the context.
Um, I think Councilmember Wood, you had some other comments,
or Councilmember Whiting, go ahead. Yep, thank you, Mayor. So we
were asked earlier to answer the question, what are the, you know,
3 capital projects you would spend the money on?
And I'm going to jump on what Councilmember Huish already indicated,
that our parks and open space, it's very apparent. You just drive around and you
see their condition. So, so before I answer the question, that,
that question, let me back up and support something.
So when we, when we say that 100% of the public,
of the, the property tax increase goes to public safety, that is
the correct answer. What we need to do is, is help
you understand, and this, this means we didn't communicate this well enough,
how public safety has been paid. So right now it's being paid for
through property tax, and we're essentially robbing from sales
tax to help subsidize our police
and our public safety. So this communication
that we're— that 100% of the tax increase goes to public safety
is true. Now puts property tax as the pillar upon which public
safety now stands. And this is what we need to communicate better. What that now
does is is it, it, it takes the,
the sales tax dollars that we were essentially robbing from sales tax to go support
public safety, and now it takes that sales tax dollars to do other things.
And that's what Councilmember Herwish was referring to, the several different hires
within the city, wage increases for the employees. And,
and so that's— and perhaps that's what some of you are wondering,
like, okay, what is now, uh, what can now be
paid for? Property tax is now taken public safety, what can we now do with
sales tax dollars that were being used toward public safety, what can we now do
with them? We're stating some of it. If you go back and look at our
budgets, we said in the budget what we would do with that money, including several
understaffed departments. Our city manager
commented we're about a third the staffing level as other
cities of our size. With that being said, these dollars
that are available now through sales tax. My number one thing is
public safety on our streets.
We have a massive need right now for safer streets,
especially in our school zones. And we need,
we need speed tables and other mechanisms to keep the kids safe.
It may shock you, but a speed table costs about $70,000 to $80,000.
And we don't just need one. We don't just need two. We need a ton
of them. That costs a lot of money.
If this tax— this doesn't go through, what now happens? Well, the sales
tax will have to go back to support, you know, our public
safety, and it gets diverted from being able to put speed tables and other
things like that in our school zones and other streets.
There was comment that I know, you know, there's some of you that I know
well that have come up and made public comment. I know
that you live on streets that are not safe.
Your streets are being studied right now. We commissioned a study that is
being done on sensitive streets
in the city, and so that we can get the best data available on how
to bring those cities to a safer level,
so we can slow down traffic, so kids can cross safely.
And that again goes back to transparency. I think that's a message we didn't
clearly communicate well enough to the city, because had
that been part of the discussion, I think people would be like, oh, wait a
second, I can get behind freeing up
some sales tax dollars to go toward making sure our streets are safer.
We just didn't communicate that, which is why I'm happy you're here. This is
part of the discussion we can now have. to help educate and
get the information out there as to what we're doing and why this
increase is so important. I'll leave it at that for the time being. I've got
comments on— well, maybe let me just say this so I can wrap up.
I just had one additional comment on the data center thing. We're hearing
people saying, we're not seeing anything from the data centers. I'm gonna tell you something.
You are wrong, and I'll tell you why. Everyone,
in this city who is 100%— 120%
area median income or lower can qualify for a
down payment to buy a house.
That money is coming from data centers so that
you can— that down payment money just doesn't magically appear. It is Facebook,
and I believe Tyson, that's putting money into an
RDA from which we are— we have created the most successful
down payment mortgage down payment assistance program in the state.
It gives you more money and is more easily qualified for than
any other city. And maybe that again comes down
to communication. That is available. There's millions
of dollars that's already been given to citizens of Eagle Mountain
to buy homes. Down payment is not something that anybody needs to
buy a home in this city. You don't need that. If you're saying, I don't
have a down payment, the down payment is available through the
RDAs that was set up that our data centers are funding into.
And it's only going to get bigger. We just approved— and this
is another conversation, and I'll probably talk about this later in the meeting— part
of the reason why we arrived to the, to the area, to this situation,
circumstance that we have arrived to, is we have built the city
upon residential housing.
And the challenge that owner-occupied residential housing, which I support,
but owner-occupied housing gets a 45% decrease on their taxes.
And so the growth
issue is one reason why I ran. I've been on the city council for a
few months now, by the way. And so that— not that
it's relevant or irrelevant, but I've been on here just a few months. Thank you.
I got involved because of growth that was unsustainable.
And so what happens is when prior city councils— I'm not
going to accuse them of their decisions, but they made decisions
where they granted developers the ability to build
thousands of homes at the fastest pace they want to
build. There's 25,000 vested units that
still exist that we can't get rid of. And those can be built whenever
those developers want to build it. And so once you give the blank check to
the developers to be able to build as fast as they want to build,
how can we then manage the growth? Because they can build as fast
as they want. And when they build, yeah, we're collecting impact fees.
But— and that came up a lot too tonight— impact fees,
we are charging them. And guess what? We're charging as much as we're allowed to
charge. I would love for impact fees to pay for all of this stuff.
The state of Utah has laws about how impact fees can be charged. We're charging
the maximum we can charge. I'm just letting you all know that.
But, but those impact fees, the state has come in for
whatever reasons it's come in and curbed how much we can charge.
So we charge as much as we can. But is it enough? It's not enough.
But we are, we are charging as much as we can. So when citizens come
up and say, what about impact fees? It's true that we should ask that question.
We're charging what we can charge, but the impact is clearly not
being paid for correctly, right? I mean, there's— they're creating more
impact than we can collect. But anyway, I bring this
up because you need to know that
this city council this year— I want you to guess
how many new housing units has this city council
approved? Zero. We have approved 33 total.
Is growth being managed? It's being managed.
How many developers have— just Twasik alone,
I had 2 developers reach out to me privately, not to these— to my fellow
city council members. Craig, I want to do this high-density development here. I want to
do this development here. And I said, it's not the time and it's not going
to happen. We're not going to support it. It's not going to happen. And they
just— and they left. You don't see the gates that we are defending.
We are defending this castle right now in a way that I can't say hasn't
ever been defended before. But since I've been involved here and
the city council has been unified in this, we are managing residential growth
exceptionally well because it's these— it's
the additional residents that are coming in paying 2010 taxes that
we cannot sustain. That math does not add up when we're
charging those new residents, those new households, 2010 taxes And
we're trying to support them through 2026 expenses. Every new resident that
comes in, we cannot sustain it.
There are not— there's not enough being collected from the new households. The growth— you're
saying, well, we have a larger tax base. Revenues have increased because we have a
larger tax base, but expenses have increased much faster.
So when people say the growth should pay for it, the growth is the issue
because we are growing under a 2010 tax rate. Even the
data centers say, well, get the data centers to pay more money. I would love
if we could tax the data centers separately. The state of Utah doesn't allow
it. I would love to do it. We cannot do that.
It's illegal to do that. So guess what? The data centers, if they had sent
a representative here, would have also been standing at the very pulpit you stood at
and would have said, we oppose the tax increase. They would have
all done that. They are laughing all
the way to the bank right now that they are only paying 2010 taxes,
and the only way we can make them pay more is to increase the
tax rate. And that tax rate has to be increased on that
same tax rate that we, that we could vote on today. That applies ubiquitously
across the city. That's the only way to get them to pay more.
I wish we could get them to pay more otherwise. We just cannot. And so
it's, it's important for us to know that growth,
unsustainable. That has caused us to
be in the situation we're at today where we suddenly have to make a decision
that's difficult. Anyway, I will— I'll pass the microphone down.
Mayor, are you okay if I talk? Yeah, go ahead. I just want to remind
the council too on item number 4, I mean, free to speak. I'm not limiting
debate necessarily. I'd just like to keep it to maybe
your position on the tax increase and supporting your position.
And I understand everything we've heard is in that manner,
but just to— With
all due respect, Mayor, I think that both of them have kept on topic with
why people are looking for answers as to what is motivating these decisions.
And I think we need to probably err on the side of allowing the
council to give an explanation. explanation of why we're going to tax people.
So that's exactly what I'm asking. Okay, what I said— I,
first of all, thank you to both of the council members who have expressed a
lot of the things that I think have been part of
the decision-making process for me. Um,
all of them will corroborate what I'm about to say. When we had this discussion,
uh, and, uh, I was actually remote It was a
discussion that began and probably ended with our
retreat in St. George. But one of the things that I said, and I still
stand by this, the only thing anybody's ever going to remember is 220%.
Doesn't matter what else we say.
The only thing they're going to hear is 220%. So we have to
be concise and clear about how we express
to them why that even makes any sense to anybody.
The reason that I voted for us to put that certified
tax rate at the level that it was is because I believe a fiscal responsibility
to fund our police force, our public safety, with a
stable revenue. That is not sales tax.
And I, I appreciate the head shakes. I do. Because let me explain that to
you, because I want you to understand where I'm coming from.
What happened when the pandemic happened and sales tax wasn't
providing anything for anybody? Did we just stop having police force?
What happened when the market crashed and everybody
started losing their houses? Did we suddenly not have a need for police force?
In fact, we had a greater need for police force.
There isn't a single person who lives in this city that does not
pay a property tax of some sort that goes directly
to the police force under this particular
proposal. Perhaps the rate's wrong, but I think in principle,
a stable revenue source to pay for public
safety should be a principle that we stand on. We have been woefully arrogant,
and we have been,
I'm not going to be loose with our lack of financial
plans in this city. We haven't had one.
When I got here, I said, where's our 5-year plan? Where's our 10-year plan?
Do we have a 20-year plan? The answer is no to all
of those things. So when you're asking how come you can't
provide that information, I'm asking the same thing. Where is the information
that we're making these decisions on, and how are we preparing for the future.
I, I think it's interesting when you have past council members
come in and say things like, uh, how, how dare you did that,
we were able to live on the income that we had there. And I think
we're here because of your irresponsibility. You left
this big pile for us. You didn't raise fees for
water, you didn't raise fees for sewer, almost to the point where we're in
the red. You didn't raise property taxes because of some crazy
conservative fiscal federal mentality
of I'm not going to raise taxes because somehow money appears
out of nowhere. And it left us in a position where we
hear you when you say our parks are in poor repair,
our parkways are not being taken care of, I can't ride my motorcycle
down the road because all we can afford to do is crack seal.
We can't raise the level of How we're taking care
of the city because we don't have the funds to do so because people in
the past thought that being cheap was a good way
of public policy. So I find
myself in this situation now of how do we course correct this?
Some of you have said, how can we do it incrementally?
If you want to continue to kick the can down the road, we can do
that. You will find that we cannot keep on pace, exactly what Craig
was saying. Thank you. We are adding 1,800 building permits a
year. That is not sustainable for our roads, for our public
safety, for fire services. We're 50 square miles.
There is no other city that is experiencing the problems that we have with
basically 2 separate cities that existed forever
with nothing in between, and we had to service both with water,
sewer, public safety, fire services.
So we're left in this place with, well, what's the decision to be made then?
Everybody's going to hate the decision. If I came in and said in the very
beginning we're going to raise the taxes by 5%, would anybody raise
their hand and say, yeah, I'm in favor of you raising taxes? The answer
is going to be no. We're raising taxes. I'm against it. I don't
want to pay it. It affects me. We are a one-income family as well,
by the way. And it affects our ability to be able to make our bills
as well. I also pushed very, very hard to have a corridor
that goes behind my house that ruins the sight and
sound of my area I live in in Silver Lake that's quiet, and it will
not be that anymore. I also voted to make sure that we built a road
from Brookhaven up to the upper part of Silver Lake out to Pony
Express so there was a safe walking route for the kids. And guess
whose house that goes by? Mine. I took all the traffic.
It's not good for me. It's bad for my family. My kids can't
go out on the street, but it created an opportunity for them to walk to
school. Craig brought up the speed tables.
I think you need to know how passionate we are about making sure that number
one, every one of the elementary schools has sufficient safe
ways to stop traffic so that they can cross. The crossing guards
shouldn't have to feel like they're going to get hit. And then we have a
speed study that is going to address every other road that has the same problem.
We had a community come in, uh, 2, 2 meetings ago talking
about the speed in their community, and they've been told multiple times, you know,
we'll find a solution, then nothing's happened. The one thing
I want you to walk away from this today, regardless of what our decision is,
there isn't anybody up here that is looking for an easy way out.
I hope that there isn't anybody that's trying to make the decisions
for a political reason, because I think that's a coward's way out.
We should be doing what's right regardless of the, of the outcome.
And for me, that's how I will vote. I'll vote for what is best
for 80,000 people. I'm not going to do what's
best for a few.
Mayor, is it okay if I go? Yes, sir, please.
I would just echo everything that's been said. I think something that hasn't been hit
on is transportation. The biggest issue that we face in Eagle Mountain
is transportation and our transportation corridors. We sit in
traffic far too often and far too long. We have intersections that are missing,
uh, traffic control signals because we can't afford to put them
in. Where does that money come from? If we continue to
pull sales tax dollars, which could fund those, those infrastructure
improvements, and we continue to allocate it to our sheriff's contract or to our public
services. Those are the things that we're really facing.
Every time that we decide we need a road to be a little bit bigger,
we've got to upsize some sewer, we've got to do some sort of improvement,
that comes out of the taxpayers' dollars. It comes out of
the general fund, and we have to decide, are we going to set some money
aside take care of those improvements, or are we going to continue to fund as
it grows? Because I'm going to tell you this, should we choose to approve this
at 220% this year, next year that is
not going to cover 100% of the sheriff's contract. News flash.
Because their fuel is going to go up, they're going to get raises, and they're
going to be back in here next year saying, you guys added another 6,000
people, we need a couple more officers. So it's not something that's going away.
It's just something that we are being asked to— what do we do to
adjust this policy so that we can get to a better place today
and work for a better future tomorrow?
We've had a lot of hard conversations one-on-one. We've had a
lot of dialogue, as we said in that retreat. We've had a lot of dialogue
as we've had those opportunities in public meetings to have the discussion
during the budget sessions.
And I'm just going to say this. I'm proud to serve with the council
members who are to my left and to my right. They are not cowards.
It's not easy to face you, and it's not easy to tell you the truth,
but that's what we've chosen to do.
Yeah, I want to at least answer Melanie's question.
Everything that's been said up here is exactly how I think all of us feel.
And we hope that it's kind of a glimpse into some
of the thought process that we've put into this,
the things that we've wrestled with, the questions that we've been asking ourselves.
But Melanie asked, like, what are the capital projects, top 3?
And for me, obviously roads,
safety, getting kids to school safely.
Those are things where there's no special fees coming from someplace else.
There's no additional dollars coming from anywhere.
And we have a family of 7 in our house. Wow. and I
was a teacher for 10 years, so it's important for me for both kids and
adults to be able to get where they need to go safely.
Every minute that you spend in your car is time that you're not
with your family. It's time that you can't be at your kids'
games or spending time with
your wife or husband or your aged parents. So, like,
roads are crazy important to me, and they will always be crazy important
to me. But the next 2 things for me are ones that
aren't sexy, and they're not ones that a
lot of people think about. But I want, when each of
you flush your toilet, for the stuff that you flush to leave your
house and not ever come back. And we need
a sewer treatment plant to be expanded so that
it can handle what we as a city have. Thank you. We're at capacity
for load, and we need to do something about it now.
And it takes 3+ years to get a sewer
treatment plant built and expanded, and it costs a crap ton of money.
So that's a huge capital project that's important to me.
Crap ton of money. Pun intended. Oh my gosh, you guys are so
quick. I didn't even think of that. And then the last
of the top 3, but there's like about 40 that are important to me,
are our water sources.
The reality of it is, is we have a ton of water and a really
nice aquifer that's under the ground, but we have woefully
inadequate infrastructure to get that water that we have
up out of the ground, and we don't have enough tanks
to store it in. And just to— it
was the 4th of July week when we put out the request to all of
our commercial businesses, all of our schools, all of our HOAs,
all of our churches. And we said, please don't water.
We said to our residents, please don't water. And we
as a city had already not been watering our parks. So why is that important?
Why do we need the whole water infrastructure?
If we don't have enough water in our tanks replenished at night,
then we can't put fires out. And we live in like a
super wildfire-prone area.
And I don't want any of the people in our community to lose
their house because we couldn't put their fire out because we didn't have enough infrastructure
to get the water out of the ground. Thank you. And we're
working like crazy. Our staff is working like crazy.
A couple months ago, there was a water line that just like burst
in the middle of behind Scenic Mountain
up there, and there were dudes from our team
working late into the night, frankly early into the morning, and it
was muddy and gross. And my husband and I went and brought them drinks and
a couple candy bars. Because I felt bad that they were working so late.
And it was treacherous for me
to walk to bring them stuff. I can't imagine what it was like for them
to work in those conditions. And that's what the people of our city
staff do over and over again. And I just— you
guys elect us because we're the ones that
go and study things out, and then we bring you back information and we make
decisions on your behalf. This is some of the information that
we have and the priorities that we have based off of the
things that you guys have told us. So thank you for being
here.
Can we move to like a policy discussion now? Yeah.
Okay. Something that's been on my mind is
how do we prevent this kind of volatility from
happening in the future. We've benefited. I've benefited personally for the last— I've
lived here 20 years and my property tax rate has
decreased as my home value has gone up. I've paid the same nominal
dollar amount. If you don't believe me, go look at your property
tax rate— not the rate, excuse me, the dollar amount
for the city has been the same. Just look at
the city. I didn't believe it when I served on city council. I'm like,
there is no way. I was told that. I went home, pulled out
all my tax records, went back to 2016, pulled out my
property tax rate. It's like $200. What I paid last year is like $210.
The way that property taxes work, it's a flat nominal dollar amount,
but that rate, as your property value is going up, you're paying the same dollar
amount. So our rate has actually been going down, and you can
shake your head no. ASD has been raising,
UFA has been raising, but the city has not been raising.
So everyone listening, go home, pull out your property taxes,
look at the city dollar amount that you've paid.
It's about the same. It's not changed.
But the cost of the sheriff per Protecting your house,
that cost has increased. So where we
have failed residents, and this isn't your fault, it's prior decisions
that were made that maybe they felt like yeah, it's okay. Data centers will come
one day, and then all of our problems will be solved. The mayor
just talked about. I've heard him say that before. Whenever that
day comes, it's not today. We're not there. So.
A couple things that I've thought about, and I would be
curious— this isn't specifically to the rate, but I would propose
that we have a code, and maybe that's something that we can work on,
that requires future city councils each,
whatever that proportion is, whether it's 100% or 50% or
60% or 10%, whatever we're looking to kind of set
that rate at to cover the sheriff's contract,
I would propose that we have a code that requires future city councils
to come back every single year, review what that— where
the council is at. If QTS comes
online and some of these data centers are— our
property taxes exceed the sheriff's contract, I would like to see
our rate go down, and I would like to pull that pressure away from the
rest But that will only happen if we have a code in place, a policy
strategically long-term that requires councils to come back and
review that on an annual basis. And I would just be curious
if the other council— we don't need to vote on that tonight, but I'd
be curious if you would support moving forward in that direction.
Marcus, if that is something from a legal standpoint that we can Put
into our city code? Yeah, I mean, you can put
it in the code that as part of the budget process, you're gonna review this,
and the future city councils will either keep that code and follow it,
or they may change the code at a future date, but then they would
go through the public process to do that. I know for me, I would've been
grateful if that existed, because we would've had gradual increases
year to year. So, so that's
one comment I have on the policy. I'd also,
uh, be— and this is more of a legal question for Marcus— the ability
for us to segregate these funds. Um,
we're, we're proposing collecting property taxes, that goes
into a general fund. Can those be segregated by
the city into a fund account that just pays specifically for, uh,
Sheriff's Office? Oh, I think he really wants to I don't
want to speak, but I can speak to that matter.
The property taxes will have to be received into the general
fund. At that point, you could— you can still create
a separate fund for public safety, but you would do an operating transfer to send
the revenue over. Would we need a code to require that? It would be a
resolution that we would bring. So this for 2027,
there were— We created a new special revenue fund for public
art and several of those. So we could
do that specifically for the sheriff's contract? Yeah. Okay, thank you.
Yeah, I'm glad you brought that up. That's actually one of the— I talked
about being willing to reduce the property tax as the
sales tax and the MET money starts to come
in commensurate so that that burden doesn't stay.
I'm definitely in favor of finding a solution
to that. I also feel pretty strongly about making sure that we,
if we're saying that we're going to put it to public safety, that there should
be something that demonstrates to the citizens that that's exactly where that's
going. So I'm glad that you said that, Kimberly. That was one of my questions
as well. I think that that needs to be clear.
I think that we need to do our budgets differently. differently, and maybe
that's something we need to have a discussion about at a later date.
One of the things that I feel like that we could have done with this,
where we're proposing a tax increase,
I believe we should have had our current tax rate budget and
a separate budget that is based on what the increase
would be so that we could actually have the very conversation that you guys are
asking about. Where would we spend the additional funds that are
being moved from the sales tax. I'll give you my list of things
that I think are important. I'm glad the person asked the 3 top capital projects.
In our meeting Tuesday, we talked about our master transportation plan.
That would be pretty sobering for you if you guys were able to see what
that cost actually is. What's even more sobering is when we sat in a
regional meeting to listen to UDOT and the Mountainland
Association of Governments tell us that we're not going to get some of these roads
for 10 or 20 years. Council Member Wood, $419 million
by 2035.
That's Eagle Mountain's portion. That's ours.
The only way that that can be paid for is by bonding or
leveraging debt. We don't have that kind of money.
We have that kind of need. We're still growing. That's not
going to change. We still have that many cars that are being added every single
year. We're being ignored largely by the state,
frankly, about what our needs are. We're absolutely being ignored
by the other side of the county as they prioritize
rapid bus that are empty,
that we all paid for, by the way, with our UTA funds.
When they're building gondolas in Salt Lake County, that should have been funds that should
have come out here and had 2100 North done 4 years ago.
I want you to know that the fight is happening with who you have right
here, and whether you decide to vote us in honestly is really immaterial to me.
If I, if I can't gain your trust by telling you the truth when the
truth sucks, then you need to go on to somebody else. But I'm going to
tell you the one thing you can trust is that I will always tell you
what the truth is, whether you like it or not. And I think I've been
pretty consistent since I started on the Planning Commission with that.
I think every developer will tell you that. I'm, I'm about what
is best for Eagle Mountain as a whole, and I've fought for that.
When we take a look at policies, policies should be things that outlast
us. If we don't do things that are going to benefit the people in the
future, and I do something that is just going to take care of right now,
then I failed. If we don't put a financial plan
in place that you guys can rely on, that's a 5 and a 10
and a 20-year plan that every council should have to come back and review
based on what the current needs are at the time, then we failed.
And I don't like to fail, frankly. I feel like that,
you know, I had some pretty specific things I wanted to accomplish being on the
council. I've hit a lot of them. There's a couple of them I'm pretty pissed
I still haven't hit them. One of them is for sure making sure that we're
financially sound. And our economic growth has not happened at
the rate that I would like it to. And I'm tired of being told by
people that that's the rate of government. I just don't believe that crap. I think
that there's ways that we can do better. So when we vote on this
today, my vote's going to be based on that. What is best for you in
the future? I'm sorry that it's going to have the same crappy effect on you
that it's having on me and my family. My wife is not in favor of
it, just so you know. And it's
going to have an impact on me and my kids, whether or not they're able
to play certain sports, etc.
But I'm going to tell you, the decision that we're going to make is going
to give us the ability to start moving traffic. It's going to give us the
ability to take care of our assets. If we let every one of our parks
die, guys, it's going to be three times the amount to fix them.
So that's kind of where I stand with that. The the last thing I want
to talk about. Capital projects. Uh, I'm not firm that all
of it should go to capital projects. I really do think that we are undermanned.
Our, our, uh, labor force is
woefully too small. Uh, and I'm not talking about people that are sitting
at desks. I'm talking about the crews that fix our streets,
our water, our parks. I mean,
if you guys knew how many employees we had at the parks, it'd probably make
you mad. I think it's like 10, isn't it, full-time employees for 68
parks? I mean, that's not going
to come from nowhere. And so when I look at this, I'm like, if I'm
going to vote for this, it damn sure is not going to be for people
getting raises at the top end. We're going to start adding bodies so that we
can tell people we did our very best to improve the quality
of life and quality of services that you should expect no matter where you live.
I support both of those policies you're talking about, by the way.
I wanted to add just a few other things. So the
city council has been fighting very hard to find additional money outside the
city for the city. I spent a week of my
year this year in March with the mayor back in Washington, D.C.,
and we worked very diligently to try to secure federal dollars
to come back to support projects that we have here in Eagle Mountain.
To my understanding, it's the first time our city has ever sent a delegation to
Washington, D.C. It's not going to be the last because we're going to keep beating
that drum. That's a week away from my family. It's a week away
from my own job, but it is worth it to
me to try to figure out other methods to pay for the needs that are
here. I know that Mayor Gray, he was the
one that identified some potential significant savings by restructuring
our relationship with Unified Fire. That's something we're going to experience next year.
That was completely on him to identify that. That could be millions in savings
for the city. And I'm grateful for his leadership in that
regard. We've— other things we're trying to do.
We have a volunteer police force that also helps alleviate
pressure on our sheriff's department. They have no funding.
And Cedar Fort has a fire department that's volunteer, and they don't have
enough funding. So Alex Carter, who's a council
member there in Cedar Fort, and I have put our heads together.
We're putting on a half marathon here in Cedar Valley,
October 10th. With money that will be raised to help our
volunteer police and the volunteer fire. We're trying
to come up with ways to get money from other sources,
even small ways. We're going to be working with the Best Friends
Animal Society where they can provide some free services to help with some animal control
stuff. We're adding those things in there. We're trying to be active, proactive,
and we're trying to approach this from the front, not the back. Yet we are
actively engaged with our state, like Legislature, there was a real
potential for the state to pass a
cap on property tax increase. Had that
passed, we would have been in a very difficult scenario, very, very difficult
scenario. And and I'm glad it didn't.
Can we phase this next tax increase? Part of
the issue is what's the state legislature going to do, and we
have to consider that and play from the front instead of the back.
Also, the state legislature has been mentioned that they want to socialize our MET funds,
our municipal energy tax from data centers. That's not fair. So you
need a you need a city council that's going to be lobbying very very much
for you at the state and with the feds to make sure we
get the best results for you. It was also stated
that perhaps the tax increase was to give the city council staff
pay increases. The city council has no staff.
Other cities have city councils with staff. We don't have a staff.
It's us. That's it.
It's been said that we're raising taxes to build a city hall, and that's false.
This has nothing to do with the city hall. Does the city need a
city hall? Yes. A lot of— there was comment saying you don't need a city
hall, you have sufficient here. That's that's an uninformed decision or uninformed comment,
and I would welcome a private discussion with any of you that feel that that
that this building is sufficient.
So I just wanted to clear up some of those things. I think oh
rec center. This has absolutely nothing to do with the rec center, and hopefully sheds
light on why we can't do a rec center yet. We have
so much going on. Let me see. I'm just trying to see. The other
thing I was going to mention is I'm going to tell you the tale of
2 HOAs because it's been brought up. Well, Craig, you're in real estate, so you
should know that this is not healthy. Let me— it is my real
estate background that it will cause me to vote yes on some form
of tax increase right now, and I will tell you why.
When I was young in my real estate career, actually I wasn't even in real
estate yet at this moment, I was on a board of an HOA Because
I was filling in for a period of time with for someone who could not
be on that board, and that individual said he instructed me.
He said, "Craig, make sure the HOA dues go up."
Like, why do you want the HOA dues to go up? This is a business
guy. Like, why do you want the HOA dues to go up? That's that's the
thing that will hurt you. You're not going to get money back from that.
He said, "Craig, I'm planning. I'm not planning on what's
going to happen to the HOA." this next year. I'm planning
at a minimum for 5 years, but Craig, I'm actually planning for 10 to 20.
And so they increased the HOA dues without a need to
increase the HOA dues. But what did that happen— what,
what effect did that happen? That HOA has never had a special
assessment, ever. When roofs came due, they had the money
for it. When they had to redo parking lots, They had the money for it.
And when properties go on the market in that HOA, they sell
in like a day because of how well that HOA
is maintained. It's because they put— they
budgeted money early on. What's interesting is there is a
subdivision immediately next door to them that did not do that.
It is currently a shuttered facility that will be knocked
down. That is what will happen. We are at a crossroads.
I know people have said, well, you are not listening to the people, Craig,
if you vote for a tax increase because the people don't want it. Let me
give a brief— this is just a 60-second historical moment.
The Battle of Gettysburg, there was a group that was assigned
to protect the flank on Little Round Top.
When the Confederate Army was coming up the hill, that group came in such
numbers and that they ran out of ammunition.
The troops said, let us— we got to back out.
We don't have any more ammunition. And their
leader said, if we back out now, our flank caves
in and they will come in behind us and we lose the war. And so
he told his troops that were with him, that were worn and tired,
put on your bayonets. And they did,
and they charged down the hill.
That changed the outcome of the Battle of Gettysburg.
Sometimes leadership requires leading people to a place they do not want
to go because we see a vision that we know we must
obtain. That's what we bring forward to you today that I ask that
you humbly please at least acknowledge to a degree. Thank you.
One question that came up when we were in our retreat and different
discussions through this is, can we create a tax change and
just create it for like a year or 2 and then roll
it back? And the fact is state law doesn't allow you
to do that, but it was something that we as a council were like,
yeah, we could get behind in that, and it's kind of unfortunate that state law
doesn't allow you to do that because there will be additional income
coming into our community soon. But right now
we have to find money to make sure we get everything accomplished.
So I wanted to let you guys know if anybody was wondering, why can't you
just do it for 2 years or a year? It's just not allowed in the
So I just want to point out maybe one, one additional
benchmarking tool if it's helpful. We, we currently as
a city, we are the 9th fastest growing
city in America, not in Utah, but in the
United States. Saratoga Springs, I don't know how they beat us. It doesn't
feel like they did. 20% faster.
Not that it's a competition. I don't want to be the fastest,
but we are. Our rate
today, we are the 2nd lowest in all
of Utah County behind Cedar Fort. So our current rate is
0.000534. Our— I'll
say sister city, Saratoga Springs, Maybe they've done a better
job of managing that rate, but they're at 0.00976.
They are also proposing a 100% increase
to their rate. And I thought about that and I thought Saratoga
Springs has a much, much larger producing
commercial base than we do. They have Costco, Home Depot.
I mean, a lot of our residents shop there. We're actually helping
them with their revenue. Every time you shop at
Costco, you're helping Saratoga Springs. When we shop here,
that helps us from a sales tax point.
If this proposed rate— and I will just say I
am not in support of this rate as proposed.
I think it needs to be lower. It needs to be certainly somewhere in
the middle. If we increase, if we
change our rate from 0.0005, and there's some other numbers
after that, but that'll suffice for my point I'm gonna make.
If we just doubled our rate to 0.0011%,
that would, new revenue generated
would be $3.4 million. So— To
be fair to our conversation, all of those dollars would
go to the sheriff's office. That would free up
about roughly just under $2 million of sales
tax revenue that's currently supporting that contract.
I think at a bare minimum, given all the road infrastructure we
have, the staffing, getting our employees just to 90%
of the median, That would be the
lowest that I would consider. But after this increase,
Saratoga Springs— and again, I'm just kind of benchmarking
because they are close to us, but I do think they have a better commercial
base than we do, although we're working on it as hard
as we can. We have an economic director that is traveling all over the
country, beating on every— knocking on every door, beating every bush. I get
emails from her Every it feels like every other day of who she's
meeting with, who she's talking to, to try to
build out our commercial base. But with with the proposed increase,
Saratoga Springs would land at about point zero zero one five,
and the next city down from there at point zero zero one four is
Ben's old employer Santaquin City. So I would just
encourage the council to consider. backing off
that number of 0.0017. And I,
I would love to, to hear an argument. You know, we can go high.
We've, we've heard several residents that have come here tonight,
and I'm mindful that we have 2 District
1 elementaries in our city. Those families, it's tight.
Title 1. Oh, I'm sorry, what did I say? Title 1.
What did I say? District 1. District 1? Yeah.
That would be college football, I think. Title 1, excuse me.
It's getting late. But we have 2 Title 1 elementaries,
and that just means that the families— we do have families that are—
that will be sensitive to this tax increase. And so in
my mind, I'm trying to balance that along with
we have needs within the city we have not kept up. And again, that's not
the residents' fault. That is a, I think, a failure of policy within
our city for the last decade. But that, that's kind of where I'm,
where I'm landing, is to come somewhere closer
to maybe where Saratoga Springs is, um,
that has a similar population rate, although they do have a better commercial
base. Hey, just a
point of clarification, if that's okay. Uh, I don't think Saratoga's
rate's 100%. I think it's closer to 50.
53%. So they're at today— their
rate today, excuse me, is 0.00976,
and after their increase, they'll be at 0.0015.
So they'll go up 6 points.
Let's talk. They don't want to sit here and listen to us blabber anymore.
Well, sorry, what do we want to do? Look, I, I'm going
to tell you that I've, I've kind of looked at this and I've, uh,
I, I've talked to a couple of council members individually and
there's such a tremendous need, but I feel like that, that probably a
better balance is to bring the rate down a little bit. And I could get
behind where Council Member Huish is at. He and I have actually talked about this.
For me, I think the 1, the 1, 5,
however many zeros in the 1,500, I don't
know what that percentage is, but for me, that's perhaps a more
appropriate number. Also recognizing that,
and I hate to even tell the citizens this, but next year we're
gonna be right back here again as we go through the UFSA.
And frankly, it'll give us a year to evaluate where things go and to
take a look at, at any perhaps increases in revenues that
we see and allow us to make an adjustment then. So that's, that's what I'm
thinking.
Can I— oh, I was just going to say, I will say Council Member Huish
brought up, we're just going to call it the 1-1. That's the median of what's
going on in our county, and that really is the bare minimum
of what we could do. It still
gives us a revenue shortfall of
$3.3 million. So,
um, I,
I think we should look at that. But I also am
sensitive to the fact that because we haven't changed anything for so,
so long, we are so far off the mark of other cities
our size like Saratoga And they're at the 1.5.
And right now, the one you guys got
as a tax statement all said 1.7. So it
is a significant step down from that.
And it's probably in the 65th to 70th
percentile of what's going on in the county as far So
one of the gentlemen that spoke earlier read a private
email that I had exchanged with him. I didn't realize it would be read,
and I'm fine that he read it, but that email openly stated
that I was already considering the 1.7% a
reduction from 1.7. So I'm definitely, definitely open to considering
a number that's different than the 1.7 number.
What number do you suggest? I've,
I've been around 1.5 is when— is about— is
what I've been looking at. I want
to manage expectations because honestly, where we land on the numbers,
we're going to be looking at this again. And I think that you need to
be aware of that. We need to be able to evaluate every year, uh,
where we actually land. Going the
other direction with this, that means that we're going to have to say no to
things. And I think if you're okay with that as citizens
and you're like, we understand there's not money for us to do all the trails,
there's not money for us to keep our parks where they need
to be, we don't have enough people to even take care of those and you'll
rally around us and help us come up with some options
to be able to deal with some of these things, then it's
probably something that we can get behind because then we're dealing with this as a
community. But if we continue on the path that was laid for
us, everything is going to be in disrepair
that's going to cost 2 and 3 times the amount to bring it back to
a level that's acceptable. So I So,
though I am not excited about going to
the 0.15, because I feel like that is, if we
felt like that's what it was, we should have started with that, frankly.
I heard what you said too, and I
felt what each one of you said about how it's impacting your homes.
So maybe that's the direction we need to go for this year.
We all hope and pray that when QTS starts this
next month, that those funds bring the revenue that we've
all been waiting for, that we've all been promised, and that as
these other buildings are built for Facebook and
QTS, that we realize those funds.
I hope this isn't the last time you're here. We're better when
you come in here pissed off and ready to fight.
Frankly, uh, it makes us better at making
the decisions that we're— that we have to make, but we also need you to
stand side by side with us when we make the decision and help us to
meet the shortfalls. So that's where I'm at. Hey,
just for the benefit of the residents, I know we've talked about this a lot,
uh, in other meetings, but, uh,
using numbers like 15, 17 is— it can get confusing.
Uh, maybe you could refer it to a dollar amount
if it's possible, or just help us understand where that's going.
So just, just to clarify, Mayor, what, what we're
discussing is reducing the, the proposed
tax increase rate to 0.0015.
That would be from 0.0017.
Yeah, and I don't think anybody there besides us understands what dollar
amount that So that's what I'm trying to tell
you. Go ahead. So here,
it's somewhere in the middle in terms of like
a tax rate. So an annual— sorry, an average home annual
increase over the certified rate, it would land somewhere between $245 to
$268 because we're sort of proposing something in between 2 numbers
I'm looking at. Call it like $2.55 or something, divide that
by 12, or sorry, divide that by 365.
So it's like a 69-cent-per-day increase, something like that.
Kimberly, can you give us a number? Can you do the math?
I've got the exact math. Yeah, it ends
up being, I can get you an exact number. No, no, not the
tax rate, 'cause the breakdowns we have go by 5% each.
And so, so the actual number, it would be a 183.02%
increase is what I— is what I'm— so
what I'm seeing is this: the annual revenue— sorry, the net revenue above
the certified rate would be $5,591,594,
which represents a 183.02% increase instead of a 220%.
But I was just saying the net effect to the residents is closer to like
70 cents per day. Yes. On the average. That's what I was talking about,
is the, the net revenue, Craig. So thank you. That's— I think
that helps everybody understand what it means. We're talking about, uh, $5.5 million,
uh, $250 a year, things like
that, around that 0.1 or 0.0015.
Is there any other comments on rate or,
or dollar amounts? I've heard a few opinions.
I kind of lost track. I think I heard Councilmember Whiting say around the,
the $5.5 million.
It's not appropriate. Public hearing time has passed.
If, if there's no further discussion, I will entertain a motion.
I haven't seen anybody raise their hand, so— Mayor,
I'll make a motion. Okay.
And then, uh, hopefully we're listening to this, so make sure I do this right,
but I move that the City Council hereby approves and adopts a
property tax rate of 0.001500
for fiscal year 2026 to 2027. This rate exceeds the certified tax
rate of 0.000530
and will result in an increase in the city's ad valorem property tax
budgeted revenue of approximately $5,591,594.
For— let's see— or 183.02%
above the city's property tax budgeted revenue for the prior year,
exclusive of new growth. Second.
Okay, we do have a motion by Council Member Whiting and second by Council
Member Wright. Either Marcus or Lacey,
do you feel you understand the motion and is it clear?
I want to clarify the tax, the 0.0015,
correct? Okay, thank you.
Yep. Is there any other questions on the motion?
Just one question for Marcus. If we have a desire to put a policy in
place for this, is this something that we do at
this time as a condition, or do we bring that back at a later date?
I think that's something you'd bring back later. If you're talking about adopting an ordinance
requiring, say, to look at it every year, as was suggested earlier,
or adopting a resolution at a later
date that after it comes into the general fund that be segregated
into a separate fund, then that would come out at another meeting.
Thank you. I think that we need to
definitely address that in our next City Council meeting.
So no other questions?
Okay, not seeing any other questions, uh, we'll go ahead and start
a vote. We'll start with Councilmember Wood. Yes.
Councilmember Whiting. Yes.
Councilmember Wright? Yes. Councilmember Clark?
Yes. And Councilmember Huish? Yes.
Okay, that passes 5-0 and carries.
Um, that is the last item
on our agenda other than one other item.
Motion to adjourn.
Second. Okay, was that Councilmember Wood and Councilmember Wright?
And all in favor of the motion, please say
aye. Aye. Any opposed?
Seeing none, we will adjourn the meeting at 10:38.
Thank you.